foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
happens
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
fire foreign
[Music]
oh my goodness that's a move for you
right there
[Music]
temperature is rising in our slot and on
the door it's all about making it to the
Champions chess store playoffs eight
super Grand Masters will battle it out
in the aim chess rapid the winner gets
the golden ticket and to keep you on top
of the action in the studio by Master
David Howell ginger tea I'm in the house
Simon Williams
and also International Master Danny
Ranch Danny welcome how are you doing
I'm doing good thanks for having me it's
awesome to have you here with us Danny
fourth stop of the tour what do you
think about the season so far but I
think it's delivered I'm a fan I've been
watching from home so I'm excited to be
here but I think as far as drama goes
the stakes are obviously High we have a
lot of people wanting to qualify for the
championship but when we combined the
tour as it was for two years with all
the chess.com events I think we were
nervous about pulling it off but I think
I think it's delivered I think it's been
great it's been a lot of fun Danny and
David you've been calling the action
from the start what are you most looking
forward to in this one Tanya I'm looking
forward to a bunch of things but most of
all It's the Return of Magnus Carlson he
skipped the last Champions chest Tour
event but he's in full now and he is
back also the debut of uh some new names
in division one oh wow it's gonna be an
exciting battle and Sai we've had three
events a different champion each time
will the aim chess rapid have a
different winner
I'm it's just going to be Magnus isn't
it I'm going to say it now I mean I know
it's not a very original answer but uh
Magnus has been playing so well recently
he's going to be the guy to beat
it's always hot too bad against Magnus
when he's playing anywhere well this
same chest rapid is one of the strongest
lineups of the season so far and take a
look at our star cost not a backup
dosatro Fabiano caruana Jordan van
forest and ferocia booked their ticket
into the AmTrust rapid in the chess kit
cup meanwhile Magnus level on Wesley and
Eduardo etorizaga earning their spots
through the plans now one new name there
is idrisaga not as well known as some of
the other names on that roster but the
chest world knows just how dangerous a
player he is Danny talk to us about ETO
Eduardo what are his key strengths Yeah
you mentioned the Chess World I think
the online chess World in particular is
very familiar with who this guy is and
how good he is he's a specialist in
Rapid because he has an aggressive style
he's been he's been putting up big
numbers in the Pro chess league for
years now had some big battles he
actually had the third highest winning
percentage in the PCL this year behind
Magnus santiacardo those are pretty big
names to be compared to so a four-time
Venezuelan Champion now representing
Spain this is a guide that is dangerous
especially in these rapid formats
dangerous and super motivated advisory
zaga now he makes his debut but one
player who's had a Bittersweet Journey
throughout the season is Fabiano caruana
he's made it to two finals but he's yet
to win an event David how do you assess
his chances in this field I think fabi's
chances are great he's been fantastic on
the tour he's been very consistent
arguably the most consistent out of
everyone he's just been a bit unlucky to
run up against informed players in the
finals so he just needs to keep doing
what he's doing and I believe in fabi's
chances
speaking of informed players another fun
favorite a Lavon aronian joins the field
Sai what do you think about the chassis
he's been playing lately Liv's been
fantastic recently I mean he's just beat
Magnus he's also been in some other
brilliant players as well he's won
nearly every competition except for the
world championship so you can never
discount live if it's on form he's going
to be a Powerhouse to face
it's going to be a tough battle at the
Champions Chester which will Crown the
ultimate King in online speed chess this
is the biggest season yet and we're just
three tournaments remaining the race to
the playoffs is heating up
each event in the Champions chess tour
is broken up into three divisions making
the CCT even bigger than ever before as
the best players in the world work to
win their division and progress to
higher divisions hopefully securing a
playoff spot big prize money and Tour
leaderboard points here's what's at
stake in the three divisions in each
event the winner of division three
receives five thousand dollars and
twenty tour points those with the most
tour points at season's end will secure
the wild card slots for the playoffs and
additional prize money the winner of
division two claims ten thousand dollars
fifty tour points and secures a coveted
slot in the next events division one
finally the winner of division one
receives thirty thousand dollars
150 tour points and a guaranteed spot in
the finals at the end year eight players
will advance to the live finals in the
end only one Champion will remain
on going into the fourth leg of the tour
let's take a look at the leaderboard
these are our standings and it is world
number two Hikaru Nakamura at the top
wall number three Fabiano caruana in
second place and number one Magnus
Carlsen in third spot not Magnus Hikaru
not a back they've already made it
through to the playoffs Fabi there is
yet to confirm his spot Simon with the
playoffs inside other players feeling
the pressure
definitely I mean every tournament that
goes by is going to get harder and
harder the pressure builds every time I
mean no one's that safe at the moment I
mean Fabiano looks safe but uh he still
hasn't won an event so this is his
chance here and all those players just
below they're going to be really hungry
to put in a powerful and even though
he's safe I guess in terms of points
you're right he wants to punch his
ticket directly he doesn't want to rely
on Grand Prix points because then you
have to keep playing every single event
you never know conflicts but I would say
if you really move away from Fabi the
other guys are literally fighting for
their lives because if they don't win an
event there's no way points are going to
get them in yeah that's the thing Danny
the beauty of the format this season on
the Champions chess tour there's so much
at stake in every game in every Division
and uh plenty of players hungry as you
say Simon for victory now if they need
those points time is ticking
sure is on and one player who's been
playing excellent chess
moments has been Vladimir federusev he
is known as the big fish and he's had to
get some big wins in to make it to
division one
Vladimir fedexev muscled his way through
the field to win division two of the
chess kid Cup in round one he had a
tough pairing tactical wizard shakriar
mamadierov after each of them scored a
win with the black pieces followed by
two draws Armageddon was forced both
players maintained laser-like Precision
until an uncharacteristic blunder or
possibly Mouse slip from mamajirov was
in a one move blunder he forgot he was
tied to the F7 Pawn the only feature in
the entire position after this round fed
a save simply cruised through his
division two opponents needing only
three or four games per round to get to
the Grand finals thanks to the Double
Elimination format it was a rematch
against memorov and in Poetic fashion it
went to Armageddon for the second time
yet again the game was decided by a
single blunder and fed a say of
capitalized with a well-timed G4 and
reside that's the end of division two he
simply plundered a mate in the end game
is precision and resourcefulness with
just seconds on the clock makes him an
absolute beast in the format we will be
focusing on division one but it's also
big action in division two and three of
the aim chest rapid and we've got a
woman Grandmaster Kathy satsala Shivali
who will be keeping us up to date with
all the action Katie welcome to the
studio thank you Tanya well and it's
your first time doing uh the other two
divisions you excited about this one I'm
so thrilled to be here
it's gonna be a lot of fun Kathy we saw
feather save making his way to division
one by winning division two there's so
much on the line for these players it's
a lot on a stake it is a golden ticket
to the first division this is one of the
few ways you can get in the first
Division and also 10 000 USA dollars
which is incredible price there are
several players who made it another but
made it Fabi made it and also Federal
still made it wow so much to fight for
let's take a look at the players who
will be fighting for that golden ticket
into division one and carry these are
our matchups who's the one player we
should keep a close eye on we should
keep the eyes on I mean tabatabai who
was so close in play-ins to qualify to
the first division in this tournament
but he was a bit unlucky he lost the
last game against Wesley so who by the
way plays in the first division now in
this tournament so he has to start all
over again in the second division we'll
keep checking in with you on that match
up and it's not just division two we
also have divisions reaction and some
might say bigger names there that's
right we have chronic playing their 14th
worlds Champion he tries so hard to get
in the first division but he has never
been lucky at this time he will start
all the way from third division his
opponent is Marcus bluebomb not the easy
one they have a bit of History they have
played a lot of games and one of the
best games that I have seen was between
these two where kramnik won with
exchange sacrifice double exchange
sacrifice so it was incredible game that
sounds like domination but luga will
have to forget about that game catty and
another name that stands out to me
another matchup is Lauren fresena
against eliano and Laurent had quite a
run in the planes taking down Magnus
Carlsen right it's not happening to
every chess players that you can beat
Magnus cross and these two are very good
friends as we know but the game was
itself not friendly president beat
Magnus Carlsen but it was not enough for
him to qualify to the first division
Marcus Carlson did and then after the uh
tournament he tweeted and I quote this
this tweet he said we eventually ended
up where we belong but you made my day
wow taking down Magnus Carlson
definitely would make anyone's day and
with all these big matchups you can
follow the excitement and the action on
chess dojo's twitch Channel that's where
it's at and even though Magnus Carlton
lost to Lauren Francine in the planes
he's been on a hot winning streak ever
since he started the Champions chess
store with a bang we missed him at the
chess kit cup but guess what he's back
under one minute now for Hikaru and wow
what a move eight minutes and 59 seconds
beaten by one second could you have
swapped Queenstown
immediately and he's shot oh and Magnus
has had no struggles against a car over
the board he should be happy
wow we have a winner Magnus Carlson
takes it he wins the air things Monsters
the very first event
um Magnus Collison will stop the day
with a match up against Jordan Ron
Forest these two players know each other
Jordan has worked with Magnus David we
want to get your thoughts on this one
what's it like when you play someone you
know so well it can be tough when your
friends when you respect each other but
you have to want to kill each other over
the board and it's not going to be easy
for Magnus this one we heard from Ketty
he actually lost one of his seconds in
the playing for this tournament in
Jordan he's a dangerous opponent
do it he did lose yesterday to Anish
giri in the playoff of the Dutch
Championship meanwhile Magnus on file
with a dominating performance fresh out
of Zagreb we heard from the world number
one thanks for another great event
always love coming to soccer nine out of
nine Danny what a performance yeah it's
a little bit of out of The Frying Pan
Into the Fire for Jordan after losing to
a niche and then here you get rewarded
with the greatest player of all time who
seems to be finding his form nine out of
nine six out of nine also a good score
he also went 11 out of 11 at the title
Tuesday recently which is a strong
tournament so Magnus as you said he's
back he seems to be funding the form
for the world number one I'm actually
quite intrigued to know how he did
celebrate did he go out did he celebrate
did he have one glass of wine or did he
go to bed early maybe we'll find out
very soon with his play but it's going
to be very exciting first game Simon
with all the burning questions there
well the other exciting matchup is uh
Vladimir Fellowship taking on Levon
aronian and David what's going to be the
key strategy for the players in that one
well I think Levon has maybe the
advantage in experience and uh in the
opening phase of the game feder say of
however especially if it comes down to a
Time scramble he's a slippery customer
he's tricky there and uh I don't think
Lev maybe has the mouth skills of
feather save so yeah early strike for
Levon that's what I try and recommend
yeah
it's going to be a fun match and we also
have the youngest ever World rapid
Champion nor the back abdusattro of
taking on Wesley so a clash of
generations but Dani also a clash of
styles I think a little bit Wesley a
super accurate player Right Wesley just
won the global Championship he knows
himself in these online formats even
though Notre Beck I think is developing
the reputation winning a world rapid
title and then also he wins a lot of
time scrambles so I honestly feel like
of all the matchups I feel like that one
is the most of a coin flip in my mind
going into the first the first set of
games so we'll see
it's going to be a fun day of Shaz not
it back up this outro he did win the
Chaska
do it again let's let's take a look at
the format the regulations of the aim
chest rapid the players will once again
be fighting in a best of four mini-match
15 minutes with a three second increment
every time they make a move the minimum
margin to win the match is two and a
half points if it ends in a tie we will
have the bidding Armageddon and it is a
double elimination bracket you lose you
go down to the elimination bracket you
win you stay in the Winner's bracket
David how's that worked out and who does
that favor yeah on paper it favors the
stronger players and you can point to
the fact that Magnus Carlson Hikaru
Nakamura have won tournament so far this
season however anything is still
possible last time we saw Abdus tour of
take the Victory and it certainly leads
to a lot of drama here we see the
players ready to kick off the tournament
a lot of drama that's what we're looking
forward to as Jordan van Forest will
start with the white pieces he's known
as one of the most creative chess
players known for his offbeat opening
Simon is that what we're expecting from
him something early on to throw off
Magnus yeah it's very hard to surprise
Magnus I mean Magnus has pretty much
tried everything himself even the bong
clouds so where I don't know can you
surprise Magnus is actually a thing
that's possible and it's funny in terms
of surprises remember because Jordan is
a second of Magnus right you you have
this sort of Gentleman's Agreement not
to play prep you've at least worked on
together so does that also make both
players think a little bit in the first
stage about exactly what weapon they
want to employ it's going to be
interesting yeah you have to be a bit of
a mean character to try and play
something that you've discussed in the
past together uh but he's full of tricks
full of surprises it's it's Magnus who
uh with with black might be the one to
ask answer questions at the early stages
I'm impatient I want to see the first
movement a couple of empty chairs there
too
wow what about prediction predictions
opening predictions are we expecting
King Pawn openings the queen Pawn
opening or something completely random
from Jordan
um the thing with Jordan is he he's just
a wild man he's completely wild and
that's why I love watching him play I
mean you can play anything at all he
plays loads of different interesting
ideas when he's playing Magnus it
probably makes sense to try and make it
a little bit funky you know Funk it up a
little bit because Magnus is oh we're
off we have some moves here we go are
you ready come on be the wizard here we
go it is what was it this must have been
E4 we have an early A6 though a
franchise yeah Simon you've got to be
happy with that one but did he play A6
and move one this is what I'm trying to
work out he did he did he indeed played
E4 A6 D4 then E6 and we have D5 so a
French with A6
fun times fun times and Simon you're the
French defense expert but A6 not the
most useful move in this position maybe
it was that glass of wine coming in
there you know the wine slip I mean A6
has moved at the late Mike Bassman used
to play uh and of course he used this
recently didn't he Danny in title
Tuesday to win every single game he used
it pretty effectively in title Tuesday
right he didn't he didn't ever lose a
game and you know David you say it's not
the most useful move but depending on
what white does right either white gets
a development lead because of this extra
pawn move or A6 down the road is often
useful right because black will play C5
and try to expand on the queen side so
especially in fast time controls it's a
flexible and and kind of a tricky move
order yeah waiting moves actually often
the most annoying to face because uh
just having the burden of the move you
want to make maximum uh kind of profit
from that and it's not clear how Jordan
will do that especially if the center
locks off Danny uh especially if the
game takes a slower Pace it's not very
good for the beginners out there though
is it because I remember when Hikaru
used to bring his Queen out and move two
right and you get all the kids at chess
club and they're like I'll bring my
queen out and it's Vicky why are you
bringing your queen out when you can't
remember
you get to then cross the line it's like
having kids eventually you're allowed to
say do as I say not as I do right and in
those cases Magnus and Hikaru are good
enough to say like ah I know that it's
not the most principle but there's some
tricks here and uh although I will say
this Jordan played by C3 we're sitting
here blabbering away it's now Magnus
who's on the clock until he just plays
Bishop before
wow we were expecting yard and run for
us to make it funky in the opening but
it looks like Magnus is the one who's
bringing in the funk while this one
heats up it's sure to be a roller
coaster ride we are also getting first
moves from Fabiano caruana and iterizaga
the players are ready to go wow Fabi
starts with the white pieces something
more sane in this one first I'm glad
we're jumping to this one next because
this was the one game we didn't have a
chance to preview out of the game I want
to say that Fabiano and turizaga have
they played each other a few times I
mentioned the pro chess League they've
both been playing for their teams for
for several years now so this is a
matchup that they're both familiar with
I think Favi with the white pieces will
be super well prepared
um and uh we'll see if Terry Saga can
can survive the the opening middle game
stage without Fabi getting a big Edge if
Fabi does have a positive score against
the results
so can iterizaga strike back that he is
such a dangerous player as well he's
known for his attack and aggressive play
with the black pieces is that harder to
achieve certainly especially against
someone as well prepared as uh Fabiano
uh on paper rated quite significantly
lower here at Arizona but in one-off
games especially rapid games where his
strengths come to the fore uh he is
certainly capable so I do think I
completely agree with Danny here it's
the opening that we'll decide especially
in the first game or two of the day I
will decide the path of this match if
Fabi can strike with white as he tends
to do against all the best players in
the world then it's going to be an
uphill struggle
his time is ticking his time is ticking
and he hasn't moved yet so sometimes
that's he's doing his meditation
sometimes the players are having a
staring contest with each other and and
who whoever blinks first now I don't
think so I think that probably we will
have a reset at some point of Bobby's
Cam and the clock but anyway yeah I
agree with you David and and uh just
that fobby has this reputation of being
so well prepared although when I've
talked with him he always laughs at that
because he doesn't necessarily feel like
he's as more prepared than any of the
other top players yet yet I think I
think that reputation um is uh is
deserved and we'll see we'll see what he
has for the first move you know I think
I'm just Scott Danny he's beating me so
many times just straight out of the
opening but uh yeah we'll see when this
game does eventually start maybe it's
that stare you know maybe it's that
stair that's getting on top of you there
David you know staring into your soul
you know so it's a it's a stereo yes
he's ready he's kind of like hey what's
going on here what I'm bouncing around I
got the I got the nerves in the chairs
um
clocks have been reset now so maybe Fabi
uh yeah just working on that internet
connection but he'll be with us soon
and I remember in the plains of the aim
chess rapid the celebration of iterizaga
when he won against Parham it went down
to the wild an incredible Armageddon and
that was a reflection of his strength in
these formats the reflection reflection
of his strength the celebration of
reflection of how much they care right
there's so much on the line here as you
guys talked about just making division
one is a borderline golden ticket right
because now you literally have an
opportunity to go all the way and
complete for the compete for the half a
million dollar prizes at the end so this
is the Players want this and don't don't
mistake their motivation or how well
prepared jerizaga will come to this game
so
it's a big moment he has this platform
playing against the big boys he's super
motivated while the players get ready
for this one we will have action soon on
and not a backup destruction starting
with the white pieces against Wesley so
a big class of generations here but
Wesley's got to be one of the hardest
players on the planet to beat how does
nordeback find his chances with white
here David oh Tanya I wish I knew Wesley
when he wants to just avoid defeat he
tends to succeed and look at those
ratings both over 2 800 wow yeah shows
how strong both these players are shows
how informed they are and how great they
are at rapid chess meanwhile D4 first
move Queen's Pawn opening after tour of
tends to start the game this way
nowadays and what will we see Queen's
Gambit London system he keeps us
guessing with this Knight here and away
from the scotch you know that's too bad
right as a fellow dubious openings
player Simon you can relate to me right
a bit too much I'm afraid the scotch is
no longer a regular part of notrex
repertoire yeah did switch to D4 pretty
consistently I have to say but
um this is this is a bit of a surprise
like bringing the bishop out to uh this
Square on 25 and uh but it's a bit of a
strange one if you don't normally play
the Tory when black plays the Queen's
Pawn as well I know that kramnick's
played in this way sometimes but not
many other elite players but probably a
wise choice against Wesley so because
Wesley so is uh known to specialize in
the opening so try to get him out of his
normal sort of routine
is is possibly wise do you think yeah it
seems like a distortion just wants to
get a position uh yeah he just wants to
say to Wesley let's play no opening
Theory research won't have helped you
here but yeah it does feel a bit dodgy
for white somehow you've spent a lot of
time with your Bishop that now sits on
the edge of the board often when that
white dark Square Bishop comes out the
B2 Pawn is a bit weird Black's Queen can
come out and uh start creating some
threats already I'm just gonna say
that's the key part of these lines is
how aggressive does black want to be
because black and play Queen to B6 and
poked B2 and if that's followed with a
quick Bishop development in a rook
coming to C8 things can those are some
of the spiciest variations anyway right
will will Wesley challenge Notre back
that directly
we'll see yeah that's the thing against
Wesley sometimes you can provoke him and
he won't necessarily rise to that
challenge he just wants to get out of
the opening with a very solid position
and yeah I think this one uh we'll see
which player is happier in a few moves
time yeah absolutely David we are
getting offbeat openings across the
boards and we've got one more matchup
which is about to start Vladimir fantasy
of aka Big Fish taking on the legend
Levon aronian who has been an icon
Slayer recently he took down Magnus
Carlsen
maximustav Duda recently in the global
chess League will he continue his farm
it's gonna be a tough one for fedexev
yeah this one is going to be tough but
fedesaf he also excels in this format
and especially online some great results
Danny you listed just a few of the
achievements of his and I'm not sure how
he'll start the game as well fedes if
he's a bit of a uh well I was going to
say Loose Cannon but uh in a really
impressive way he can kind of keep his
opponents guessing in the opening yeah I
agree I think he's I think he's sneakily
under underrated again you know when you
when you start listing out names he's
not historically been a household name
right but he he was the the MVP of the
protest League finals and again the
match-ups that he was facing every game
there were super impressive so he's been
playing fantastic chess lately and and
uh
well we'll see I mean he okay he also
hasn't moved yet either so but the
clock's just started so this game is
about to get underway Connie we were
talking about the the room game behind
them yeah and Lev is clearly winning
that yeah look at those boards look at
those books there I think Lev you know
he's definitely got the room game very
strong usually loses the room game in
fact I've seen him playing from that
room with that exact lighting more more
times than I than I would even want to
talk about so um but that's a new room
for Liv or at least uh
it's so cool to have these chess boards
and these chess books around for all
that extra motivation that you need when
you're running on seconds here you've
got moves and it's a Spanish yeah
Spanish opening the Royal Lopez and Kate
Berlin played by aronian not necessarily
A Bad Thing against fedes though because
fedes for sure won't take the easy way
out won't go into any drawish or dull
end games and we see all the pieces stay
on the board and this of course is
Mainline Theory but uh okay at least
tension guaranteed Bishop she five very
ambitious stuff by fedexv creating this
pin on the Black Knight
what do we think of this the theory is
still going to be these both these guys
I expect to play pretty quickly and
they're they are delivering look at this
and the voluntary Retreat to H4 these
are guys who've come come with uh
something something at home that they
cooked up so maybe that'll be the first
surprise Lavon is giving pause to that
one how do you explain that Retreat
because usually white wants to make that
move once black gets to that Bishop
advancing that H Pawn one step ahead but
fetusive just coming back what's the
point of that move
I admit I am not a Spanish expert
anymore at some point no I'm kidding I
don't know if I was ever a Spanish
expert but I think one of the obvious
ideas is is to maybe come to G3 with the
bishop and sort of over assault this
Pawn on E5 Bishop E7 is an interesting
move too because initially you think the
E5 Pawn is hanging but because of
tactics that's not the case so
so anyway this is interesting that
immediately followed by Bishop we want
to show real quick why Knight takes E5
is not that big of a deal I think it's
because black can just take on e4 and at
the end of these lines The Exchange
actually will favor Black because I
think the opening of the position allows
blacks piece to be a little more active
at the end so interesting
um but again I don't know I made David
you're the you're the strongest player
in the room you're supposed to answer
the really tough questions why Bishop H4
uh that is a really tough one uh you're
right there Danny and uh yeah I think it
is as you say just to come around I
think he wants to gain time against this
Pawn not by taking it immediately but
once you come around you do Force black
to react I'm wondering here just how
black defends this Pawn first of all do
you really want to spend another move
with your Bishop the third move with
this bishop to kind of plant itself on a
bad passive squad on D6 just to defend
maybe this is uh Lev's idea
um I'm assuming that uh further save has
a plan in mind because if you don't
retreat your Bishop right now then yeah
basically this tactic is always going to
exist you have to watch out for this
trick of Knight takes C4 all the time
wow so yeah very tense so it does start
with an auntie Berlin but things are
heating up in this one meanwhile we are
also getting started on the Fabiano
Carana against Eduardo iterizaga if
Eduardo takes this it would be a big
upset on the paper huge upset I mean you
pointed out that even though I keep
referencing the processity just because
it's where we've seen these two guys
play but Bobby has a plus record Bobby
has a plus record against a lot of
people in the PCO we think of names like
Magnus and Hikaru I think I think first
especially because of this year but
Bobby has led a couple of teams to two
protest League titles and so again we
always talk about that not just because
he's a friend I think he's often
underrated in Rapid and Blitz formats
and he's consistently been in the final
match up here at the CCT right and he's
lost twice but I I think he's uh way
more dangerous and Rapid I think the
reputation of the 2018 World
Championship will never will never not
follow him wherever he he goes right but
I I expect that fobby will be the
favorite big time in this matchup and he
actually won a medal at the world rapid
Championship currently uh recently in
Almaty he's
and we've seen big improvements by Fabi
it feels like Fabi version 2.0 he has
been having quite a performance this
year he's looking for a win in the
Champions chess star he's been in the
final twice can he do it in this event
and David we've got moves we do have
moves this game started as a Karo Khan
defense The Exchange variation so we saw
a trade of Pawns in the center very
early and now we have something that we
call the Carlsbad structure where it's
going to be a bit closed for a while but
both sides will maneuver around and
actually both sides can play on either
side of the board so early stages in
this one of course a tourizaga is known
as a caricon expert so he's well versed
in this type of structure I will say
Fabi maybe being a bit less direct than
I expected him to be yeah it's quite
funny actually we mentioned that uh Fabi
and his his Blitz play his rapid play
and if we go back to the World
Championships where he played against
Magnus Carlson and he lost the world
championships in the in in the quick
section and everyone was just saying
he's a terrible he's a terrible quick
player he can't play Blitz chess so then
since then he's just got better and
better he was always good of course but
he seems to be improving at the quicker
time limits all the time so it's uh
something he's definitely worked on I
think and this is what's happening most
of the time now quick chefs is it the
way forwards looks like it and do you
think that exactly that world
championship is what motivated Fabi to
get better in these formats it's funny
I've talked with him a lot about this
and he father's version of that was okay
he would argue that a lot of people lost
to Magnus and Rapid around that time but
if you go back to what actually happened
in the games a lot of people may not
remember that in game one of the rapid
tiebreaker Fabi was was much better and
actually felt confident and was feeling
good and that he actually blames that
result much more on sort of losing his
way psychologically after losing the
first game things kind of started to
tilt but from his perspective it wasn't
just the time control so
um anyway I I would argue that
regardless of whether someone agrees
with it right perspective tends to be
reality for most people and I think he
he knew he needed to work on it if he
was ever in that spot again and he
certainly has committed and um anyway
it's why he's been arguably again he has
yet to win one but you could argue that
Fabiano caruana has been maybe the best
player in the champions tour for the for
the most of the season so we'll see if
you can deliver again this week yeah
he's been Runners up into events
fantastic performance so far on the tour
and speaking of the 2018 World
Championship let's go back to Magnus
Carlsen taking on Jordan van Forest wow
there's a lot that's happened Queens off
the board This is the End Game David how
are we assessing this position yeah we
haven't been playing too long but
already Queens are off all the Bishops
are gone it is an end game and white has
more space if you look at the Pawns in
the center of the board and on the king
side white has advanced quite far there
but due to the lack of pieces actually
white has a lot of responsibility now
what has a lot of squares to cover and
black is Rock Solid especially with
knights Anything Can Happen they're
gonna jump in and around I'm seeing the
Black Knight jumping into White Queen
side very shortly I think objectively
it's roughly in the balance but we all
know magnus's reputation in the end game
can Jordan hold his own there that's the
big question is he the best end game
player Magnus
I think he's the best end game player of
all time I mean I'll just I'll write say
it but I think Magnus Magnus loves the
opportunity to sort of just outmaneuver
people and I don't want to use the word
Swindle because he's not winning in
games by swindling but his ability to
just keep pushing is based on the
psychological Edge he often brings to
the table and I think he just he doesn't
look at an equal position and say equal
draw he says equal okay I'm the better
player so an equal position gives me
more chances to win
yeah I mean it's a pretty standard
structure this you get from the French
defense I mean whenever on the black
side of this I mean I've I'm pretty
happy because I've survived the opening
for a start yeah
um but um if you look at the weaknesses
in the position the one good thing that
black has is that not really any Pawns
of blacks are serious weaknesses but
white has this Pawn at the base of the
pawn structure in the middle of the
board and that is a weakness and this is
something which is uh very prevalent in
this type of structure but of course it
should be even at the moment and it's
easier to play with more space and I
think white should just push his King
side pawns try to create some weakness
over there but moving the king into the
middle seems very sensible as well wants
to overprotect that D4 Pawn just to make
sure that maybe then he can move the
knight from B3 I don't know if we want
to analyze this at all before we this
may end up being the game that's over
first if we want to just quickly look at
it but it's um I think the king will
come to D3 and go over protect the D4
pawn and then
and then white maybe tries to use some
sort of grip Palm structure on the king
side advancing for this G5 break the G5
break is often the the most dynamic one
because if G5 occurs black only has bad
choices if you take it you always give
the outside passer and if you leave it
white capturing H6 creates a weakness so
there's of course there's these crazy
ideas where you sacrifice everything for
a queen but that won't be the case here
so anyway I think that while we're
applauding Magnus I don't think Jordan
is in any danger in this game
well so you would be happy to see
Freddie the F Pawn Gary the g-pawn
advanced on the board even though Queens
are off the board there's still
potential to create weaknesses here
I'm actually happier that you you know
the names
that is yeah that is that's amazing
that's that's put a smile on my face and
if anyone out there doesn't have a clue
what we're talking about uh then I I get
the pawns names depending what file
they're on so you have the pawn on the
right hand side it's on the H file of
course it's called Harry after Dirty
Harry the character and they've all got
funny little names there but we are
seeing on the board here David many
exchanges I mean uh you're you're an
in-game expert I think it's fair to say
you love playing 200 plus Move games
don't you David sorry to say and um who
would you prefer to be here yeah you're
basically calling me a boring old man no
no no no no no no no no
I do like my end games and I just like
Danny would choose white I think there's
less risk for white it feels like if you
just protect everything you have a draw
at hand but so yeah if you want to play
for a win I was about to say Jordan
paused at that moment it looks a bit
strange he's changed change the pawn
structure he wants to maybe break with
this Pawn now he has full defense over
his Center maybe he's just going to
retreat his Knight say everything's
defended and go for Glory on the king
side yeah I don't really think he's in
much danger here I was surprised by Rook
C3 and of course the computer only
giving a teeny Edge for white but I
think from a practical perspective white
is controlling all the cards right
you'll play G4 at some point you will
decide whether F5 or G5 is worth it
maybe that's part of magnus's
psychological plan is he believes in
himself enough to say come get me big
fella and see if you give me some
chances once we're both under time
pressure but by the way speaking of time
pressure I think that's the one thing we
haven't called out it's regardless of
the X's and O's Magnus is is doubly up
on the clock and if you if you just take
another four minutes away for both
players and not much has changed that'll
be the thing Magnus is playing for
and Jordan bond for us right now in full
control he's the one with all the pawn
breaks in the position the one with the
active Rook eyeing the beep on weakness
that black has potential breaks can
Jordan try and grind this one out and
get more out of this position we will
check back here but for now let's get an
update on Fabiano caruana taking on the
underdog of the aim chess rapid Eduardo
etrizaga there have been a few moves uh
David since we lost checked in what do
we make of the developments yeah so this
game we mentioned the pawn structure it
has changed slightly and that's mostly
because of the development of the pieces
I'm looking already at uh what's
happened here the outlines of the
position and ituruzaga has planted
Black's light squared Bishop on a very
odd Square on E6 it looks like it gets
in the way White's Queen meanwhile
putting some pressure on some pawns uh
if everything is balanced if both sides
just get developed then I'm liking
what's chances I don't know about you
Daniel Simon it's interesting because
the bishop is on E6 but it's sort of by
Design right because if why were to take
on F6 I think most viewers would say hey
that doubles black spawns right but I
think if you take F6 then the bishop
looks perfect there guarding the D5 pawn
and and blacks pieces will develop so I
think this is you know still very equal
I like I like this move H6 sort of
putting the question to the bishop which
diagonal do you want to stay on because
if you if you commit back to E3 to guard
H6 then eventually maybe black has E5
coming so anyway not to get too
technical yet but I think both players
are actually doing a little more deep
looking here than first meets the eye
because they want to make sure their
pieces are on the right squares for
their plan oh wow and he commits I'm
here goes a double-edged game Simon this
is this is right up your alley we've got
the bishop pair and bad pawns yeah I
kind of like white though yeah
definitely I mean it just looks a bit
clumsy for black to put that light
Square Bishop in the middle of the board
there I mean uh I think there's two ways
you evaluate a position generally you
look at the pawn structure and then you
look at the pieces and I always say the
pawn structure is like the skeleton it
kind of holds things together and the
pieces are like your organs they kind of
make the skeleton work and here just
White's skeleton is really lovely
everything's defending each other but if
you look at black skeleton he's got so
many little weaknesses the white Pawn in
the middle of the board uh the Double
pawns on the right hand side yeah and uh
also the pieces okay Black's got two
Bishops but two Bishops are not always
good there's already some tactical uh
tricks here that uh David you might
better show us there and black hats play
a defensive move there to stop those uh
tactical tricks yeah there might still
be tactical tricks Simon I'm just
looking at the position now and I'm
thinking okay maybe you can get away
with for example sacrificing I have a
piece only six I love that idea I'm
looking at it like can we please show it
thank you for having the analysis board
because I'm like a kid in a candy store
Rook takes C6 if Queen takes E6 you win
the queen and if Pawn takes E6 there's
Bishop takes G6 check which I mean let's
go Bobby like that's the kind of chest
we want to see on a Monday morning right
Monday afternoon my time's I'm still a
little jet-lagged everybody forgive me
so depending on where you are but I love
this idea I think I think we might see
it yeah and he's boss he's taking a
thing I I agree with you guys I think
this is exactly what he's thinking about
Rook E6 in his way on his radar will he
go for this sacrifice this is a critical
moment yeah critical moment look at it
to rosaga just looks super nervous like
you said Tanya just looking back a
minute ago it looked like he was praying
he was like please don't hit me now give
me time to Castle if black does get the
time to put his King to safety it's
going to be a very tense model game
middle game and actually I have to
disagree with Simon these are my
favorite uh type of Pawns it's my
favorite porn structure they're so
mobile and Black's King will be super
safe tucked behind them so this feels
like a key moment yeah we'll probably go
for it look at Eduardo he's looking away
he's also looking at these lines he
doesn't want to see that Rook sacrifice
that exchange sacrifice on the board
right now he's doing a Beth Harmon isn't
he he's like
get the pieces on the chessboard yeah
it's just having a little look on the
ceiling yeah what's happening up there
and
I really hope we see a sacrifice now
come on we need that Monday sacrifice
just throw the piece at him get the
caveman chess going and get the rock and
roll on the board will he will he do it
should we have a little vote Yes yesaga
head in hand I wonder sometimes if you
look at the player you're you're facing
I know Hikaru does that a lot where he's
looking at the player's reaction but oh
wait no he goes the other way I was just
going to say if you do this black gets a
lot of pieces for the queen and I didn't
I was going to highlight that this is
exactly why the the same idea doesn't
work with the other move order and yet
Bobby says no you're wrong or or he's
wrong because this is Queen takes E1
Knight takes E1 and
Alive even better what keeps the queen
black will be up the exchange a rook for
minor piece and did he miss this Dave I
mean possibly just misses Knight E5 I
mean you know you're a bit Rusty the
first game this could be a major upset
just looking at the evaluation bar
already I mean with the black pieces
um I really I mean Black's just doing
well here surely yeah more material two
Pawns in the center uh fabby's not
giving much away with his facial
reactions there
um yeah this is strange I don't think he
missed it I think he just
maybe he assumed okay white tonight can
go and take this black pawn in the
center things are opening up against the
black queen and king but black is just
going to Castle to safety and I don't
think you have enough ammunition here I
don't think you have enough white pieces
to justify the sacrifice I completely
agree and even if you play Queen takes
B7 here black will castle and then the B
file becomes a uh a weakness instead of
an asset and so this is this is um an
exchange sacrifice misevaluation gone
wrong I think you're right David that it
was less about a calculation error and
more about just maybe misevaluating the
chances of this position because
very strange sizes it's very strange
that someone like Fabby one of the best
players in the world ever to misevaluate
a position I I don't really believe that
because he's such a strong player he's
so experienced and he's taken loads of
risks here I mean he had a good position
when he got a good position why take so
many risks unless you miss something I
think he maybe just missed this move I
don't know I mean why else I don't see
you know you have to have some concrete
here I mean you mentioned Knight takes
E5 but you can't just hope it works
you've got to make sure that it works
this is a mistake that a lot of lower
rated players do they they play an
attractive looking tactic but they don't
calculate it visualize it quite far
enough ahead but Fabi Fabio is not a low
rated player he's he's a fantastic
player so um yeah so I'm really
surprised yeah I think uh he's just
banking on this Knight takes E5 move
hoping that black takes this Knight back
and there will be some action along the
e-file with a pin but what if black just
castles I'm not even sure which way
black should Castle okay he has played
this move this is the position on the
board but for example if black even
castles Queen side this Knight is pinned
you're not kind of getting anything else
other than a pawn for your exchange and
Plex piece is all very active
it's funny how much we disagree about
where fobby went wrong here I'm going to
continue to disagree because I don't
know that I don't know he miscalculated
as more as I think I I always try to
have these self-reflective moments where
I try to be like are we just biased
because we can see the eval bar right
and we're looking at this position and
we see the edge for black but is it
really that much because after Knight
takes E5 if Bishop takes C5 if we can
show it David Knight F3 is going to come
you're gonna win the piece back with
interest the pawn on D5 is weak and so I
think sometimes we look at it and we go
wait like did they blunder or is Bobby
like look I've got a lot of compensation
here this is harder to play for black
than maybe humans realize and we're just
suffering from eval biasitis because we
can see the Evo bar but is it is it a
case when you've got a good position
you're taking risks right because you
are unbalanced in the situation is that
is that the right thing to do principle
wise I mean it's very risky uh to to
take such risks when when you have a
good position anyway when your position
is equal or maybe worse I can maybe
understand this decision more but it's a
yeah and but of course I can see an
evaluation party and it does help my
thinking that uh it's in Black's favor
sure Fabiano caruana one of the best
calculators on the planet there with the
move order switch up and now it looks
like he's in trouble Eduardo eterozaga
calmly brings his King to safety on the
king side also notice how there's a pin
along the E file so the Knight isn't
that free to jump around Fabi in trouble
here and I don't know if you guys saw it
but there was a little bit of reaction
there by Fabi he had a head shake after
that night jumping onto the center
blocking the e-line it could very well
have just been a blind spot I love that
you're the first person to call it the
body language that's usually my job that
feels so good that I wasn't the first
person to point that out but I did see
it and Fabi is one player who always
gives us crap for like you guys read way
too much in the top player body language
and I'm like well I can always see when
you blunder so you can say that um but
no I agree I did see that I think
whether I don't know whether it was a
full uh full Chagrin or if he just kind
of acknowledged that this is going to be
harder than he thinks so this is It's
Tricky I kind of want to quickly go back
to the to the Jordan game versus Magnus
just because we started there if that's
okay I'm not sure if I'm if I'm allowed
to make that call or not but you know by
just calling I think it's a good one to
check on just because even though I
expect it to be a draw we did see this
G5 structure which is kind of White's
main plan H6 is going to fall here even
though Magnus is currently up a pawn and
if time pressure ensues Knights are some
of the trickiest pieces we've got the
bullet Chess Championship coming up this
is about to be a bullet battle with a
little bit of increment yeah and we all
know how badly Knights suffer against
Rook spawns in this case Harry the H
porn for uh Simon here could play a
decisive role if Magnus isn't able to
deal with that and okay material balance
will be restored who would you pick here
evaluation boss says draw but which side
do you think it's easier to play I mean
I'd definitely pick white here because
uh when you when you get to night
endings the most precious past Pawn to
have is the wing pawn and you can see
that Harry over there it could be strong
luckily why I don't know about luck but
Magnus has his King in front of that
pawn but a problem that you have when
you're defending against a Rooks Pawn is
that your knight can only defend it from
one side it can't jump off the board and
defend it from Another Side so uh I
definitely pick white here but unless
white can get his King in there's not
much material on the board you're
playing a pretty good end game player I
mean he's not bad is he if you're
playing me you'd have some chances
you're playing Danny even more chances
you're playing David no chances and um
yeah I mean sorry yeah we've got it
we've got to get it big on me all you
want I think we're about to see a
repetition it was glad we came here
because it's the final instructor oh you
don't think so no I think Magnus
any chance that of that happening
certainly now and uh Jordan he shook his
head yeah he liked this move he could
have gone the other way with this King
he could have cut out this option and I
think like you said Danny we would have
seen a draw within moments but suddenly
big question does white push the pawn
allowing the black king uh to either
step forward or to the side and that
pawn will be weak forever picked off
soon or do you move your knight forward
where the black king again is allowed
forward suddenly big question to answer
yeah I apologize I I was maybe just
thinking about Simon picking on me I
guess but no I I it's obvious that the
white king needed to go to F3 Danny you
will get your revenge I'm sure we've got
plenty of days left my friends is gonna
fall you're right Tanya this is Jordan's
not got plenty of time left he's got 25
seconds on the clock the line is on the
board David the one that you were
calling out now there are two pieces
attacking the h-bawn I don't see a way
for white to keep it together yeah that
pawn is dropping and well Jordan pushes
his King to D4 what is the expected
replay after Knight takes Pawn suddenly
there's a threat of Knight trade the F4
Pawn as well for white is hanging yeah I
think the one the one lucky thing Jordan
has going for him is just that F7 F7 is
tender the moment the black king gets
too aggressive right you play Knight G4
check and on King G6 King E3 and you say
all right I screwed up now show me right
and like and it will black be able to
make progress without Knight H6 coming
in asking Magnus to show how to win a
pawn up that is scary it's really scary
I mean for sure you can ask Magnus a lot
of questions but I've seen him win so
many unwinnable endings uh just sitting
on the you know sitting here he does it
so often especially when uh the the
clock is very low but I mean how how
realistic do you think that is David I
mean uh here that Magnus couldn't can
win this well that's the thing if it was
anyone else in the world I'd say
Jordan's gonna draw
um we also see the evaluation bar so
objectively it's should still be a draw
yeah Magnus still needs a bit of magic
but yeah we've seen him milk these types
one of the things I always ask in these
positions is if I could pass the move
would that be progress and I think one
of the problems is even if black could
pass the move the white king will now
sit on E3 and F3 and if the D4 Pawn ever
pushes you'll go to E4 so I don't
and you can't you can't exchange pawns
so I'm sort of I'm sort of wondering if
uh if there's any real way to trick
white here but if there is Magnus
Carlson we'll find it full disclosure
but I I still think that Jordan is gonna
hold a draw despite blundering to get
here yeah the clock situation though is
uh another
huge huge Factor right now if Marcus can
step a trap whether it's only one or two
moves to stay in the game I'm not sure
it's going to be easy for Jordan and
already you can threaten a Night
Exchange he's considering Magnus
throwing his Pawn forward now his past
d-pawn uh to attack that white knight
now that the king is slightly sidelined
itself for white but uh big moment yeah
15 seconds on the clock the last player
you want to be trying to defend this
position against in the pla in the world
is Magnus Carlson Jordan van Forest a
big task a big ask of him right now can
he hold the draw here black can start
looking at advancing down the board with
that deep on guys predictions will this
end in a draw or will this be a Magnus
win
oh man now we're on the spot no pressure
Danny
you know just to avoid uh being the
person who always picks the most
dramatic storyline I'm going to say that
it's going to be the draw because I'm
accused Often by chat by the way hi Chad
we see you
um as uh looking for the the biggest
dramatic storyline but I think Jordan
will hold although right as I say it I'm
now looking at the d-pawn and starting
to look at some real crazy lines of
Simon now Magnus will crush it no no
doubt about it I mean Magnus is just
gonna grind it grind it find an
opportunity the problem is Jordan has to
play so accurately I mean even though as
you pointed out Danny it's not easy to
win at all uh Magnus can keep trying
stuff and as soon as I say that they're
repeating Kings but um yeah I mean it's
not easy to win but David what do you
reckon you've got to have that you're
gonna have the deciding yeah the
deciding what I don't know Tanya you
need to vote too but I'll say draw
because it feels like Jordan has set up
really nicely with his pieces and he's
going for the win he refused the third
time repetition here so Magnus going to
try till the end yeah Magnus he'll play
till King versus King if he needs to
we've seen that before from him but
whether he's successful win and that's
another question it feels like Jordan's
got his night on a perfect circuit right
now white tonight is stopping the
advance of Black's extra Pawn the Deep
one and it can give the black king some
annoying checks too F5 is always going
to be a way to try and trade pawns uh
for white later if you can arrange it
well I'm talking myself into a corner
here but I'll say draw the good news is
we don't have a lot of other games to
get to we already had two quick draws
between oroni and fedoc and so and Notre
back abdusa toroff respectively so we've
got this game in the Fabiano game so I'm
willing to just stay right here until we
we see Magnus show us whether he's going
to find a way or not
12 seconds for Jordan van Forest he does
repeat with the knight and king and
that's all that he has to do right
shuffling around with the Knight and the
King makes sure that black skin doesn't
get active but is there a potential
winning plan in this position for black
here
I think you have to be able to advance
Steve if we want to bring up the
analysis more we might as well show how
it works right so if if black can
advance the d-pawn not really because
you have hopes of queening but because
you can distract the white king in the
right opportunity for the black king to
go to G6 and F5 the problem is you have
to do it where the Knight is also
somehow sidelined himself because
otherwise F7 is a problem or as we see
now check right so the right way to do
this is to advance the d-pawn that first
distracts the Knight to B4 David and
then it then distracts the king only at
that time if the Knight is sidelined on
the queen side and the King has
retreated could black win so we'll see
might be three great colder Danny it's
on the board he wants to get the Deep on
moving but but the thing is you have to
okay and now now Jordan sees a chance
actually I think this is a great move I
think Jordan has just clinched that
because you get one more Pawn off the
board and suddenly you're in sack
territory right sack the night for the
remaining pawns and you should be able
to draw
good strategy isn't it David I mean when
when you're uh trying to draw exchange
off as many pawns as you can because
there's less to worry about really you
know there's just one trap in the
position just to show you it didn't fall
for it if you've taken this point I love
it
heart attack don't make Tanya fall off
the chair there you go if you take the
pawn bad things happen yeah if the
knights disappear black will win due to
this protective passport but this didn't
happen in the game and uh Jordan's still
holding the balance this is the game
position he will trade off at least one
set of Pawns and should make a draw
shooting another update that idrisaga
Fabiano also ended in a draw so that's
three draws will this be the fourth
drawer right now Jordan seems to be
there not anymore he blundered his
Knight he walked his Knight into a trap
because the Nikon's before the night
guards do you know what he just never
bet against Magnus guys 96 can be seven
and then oh can be seven the knights out
of squares
you probably would have just repeat it
and now any way you lose the night but
White's coming out of after the pawns
it's not going to be enough David
what is happening can you just take that
white and I just take it and then Knight
F4
king of fire and then just keep pushing
oh it's so tricky now though white snake
has escaped but the pawn is rolling
maybe Magnus has played it perfectly now
the white King has to give way and oh my
God
and this is how it's done yeah I mean Dr
Carlson strikes again normal normal you
know normal Magnus Carlson you know just
when it looks like it's going to be a
draw uh he he just finds the way to put
problems on his opponent and uh and he
wins and immediately it turns off the
camera he says my job is done the Magnus
touch there what a win that was in a
position that was an absolute draw
Jordan held it together a fantastic end
game the Magna starts the Golden Touch
call it what you want but that was a
Magnus Carlsen show David what an end
game what an end game and Justice we
were about to ride off that game as a
draw Magnus worked his magic and uh
meanwhile for Jordan it was tragic that
his Knight got uh trapped on the edge of
the board and it was this position where
things started to go out of control here
maybe just taking a set of Pawns off the
board and retreating with the white
knight should have been the way to
safety looks like you've got everything
covered the white King's Super Active
black cannot make progress but this
Knight check led to a fateful blunder
the king slid across to D7 and after
Knight B8 White Knight was caught on a
poor circuit on the edge of the board
and we saw it here it was pushed to A6
and from there we saw how the game ended
let's just show this one more time
because this was actually the key move
uh Knight to F4 and Black's Pawn was
deciding this game white is simply stuck
and black did go on to win
as Magnus Carlsen do this just
incredible stuff once again squeezing
water out of stone there and that means
we've got one win in the first round of
the aim test Rapid as all the other
three games did end in a draw Magnus
Carlsen takes the lead his fiery form
does continue what a fantastic run a lot
of fun there Danny yeah and Magnus shows
that his form will continue we were
wondering will he be a little tired from
the dominant victory in zagrev or will
he show up ready to fight he answered
the question right there and even
against his friend he grinds out a game
that maybe should have been a draw and
the hard bars too is Magnus just went
with black so now now he gets white and
and that's what it is to play uh the
best player of all time so yeah I mean
it's just his determination really I
mean uh Magnus he never gives up other
players would have said okay we're
taking the draw Magnus just keeps on
going and going and going and uh it's
really tough to play against someone
like that it really is quite a big
challenge when you're facing the world
number one a Magnus Carlson and speaking
of challenges you don't want to miss our
coverage tomorrow because we've got a
very fun challenge that's coming up as
Magnus Carlsen takes on our very own
David Howell in an air in an in an
earthing challenge David that was a fun
one here's a sneak peek
yeah that really just looks like you're
moving upon like a knight
does this actually work
you tell me
I'm guessing I know you're guessing just
sometimes your guesses are right
no problem
oh I just saw a nice way to list again
spotted my trap yeah I wish it's day
four nice
he sees everything one thing is like the
play just this way but to watch this
must be
what exactly was that there was that a
blindfold game because none of the
pieces have markings pretty much okay I
was trying to figure it out I'd never
seen that but that looks like it was
that would be a tough challenge actually
yeah just playing with air devices we
could only see white pieces and black
pieces but we had no idea what they were
so uh we had to keep the position in our
minds and who won we're going to find
out to find out tomorrow oh that's
coming up tomorrow you don't want to
miss the big room who won that add
things challenge between a Mac
David Howard for now we're gonna go into
a twitch break for our non-subscribers
and those of you who are subscribed stay
with us
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
oh my God
[Music]
for over 75 years we've witnessed
moments that will last forever from the
heroes we admire to the joy of watching
them play
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game whom forever faster
now weekly compete in the community
bullet brawl Arena and win Diamond
membership anyone is eligible to throw
their hats in the ring and prove their
speed chess prowess
all you have to do is join the Community
Club on chess.com and register for the
arena use exclamation point BCC in chat
for all the details
the most elite bullet tournament returns
you don't want to miss the fourth ever
bullet Chess Championship featuring
Magnus Carlson for the first time he'll
join reigning champ Hikaru Nakamura 2021
champion alireza ferrugia and more to
fight for their share of the 100 000
prize fund it all kicks off on July 17th
at 9am Pacific use exclamation point BCC
in chat for all the details
[Music]
thank you
seriously
[Music]
Angels is an intelligent system that
analyzes your game prevents mistakes and
develops recommendations for improving
your skill
thank you
unlike your potential there with aim
chess analytics and lessons you can sign
up now for a first month free and the
code is CCT find it at go.chess.com
aimchess and one player who needs to
unlock his potential right now is Jordan
van Forest he has lost the first game to
Magnus Carlsen but we all know what a
fighter Jordan is take a look at what
makes him so dangerous
[Music]
modern farm Forest comes from a famous
chess family
the Dutchman has amassed an army of fans
thanks to his creative and aggressive
playing style in fact he was even chosen
as one of Magnus Carlson's seconds due
to this fact and due to his opening
ideas Jordan has become a fixture in top
level International tournaments
often he surprises his opponents early
on he goes for their King as early as
possible and he keeps them surprising on
every single turn this means he claims
the scallops of experienced opponents
and can beat anyone on his day
this is especially useful in Rapid chess
and will stand him in good stead in the
coming tournament Jordan's big
breakthrough in Elite chess came at the
2021 Tata steel Masters in vikanze
there he defeated Countryman Anish giri
in a playoff to win the title ahead of
others such as Magnus Carlson Jordan and
Anish giri have actually had some
fascinating battles throughout the years
in this position Jordan was able to
display all of his creativity to win a
model game in the 2022 Tata steel
Masters here Jordan had the white pieces
he is completely in control thanks to
this powerful knight supported by two
extremely dominant past Pawns
all that is needed is a check meeting
sequence and a final assault against the
black king but where is the Breakthrough
Jordan surprised all the viewers and his
opponent by playing the move Rook to H3
lining up an attack against the black
king threatening to take a pawn with
check
and the whole idea is that this Rook
sacrifices itself to break Black's
Fortress after The Rook is captured
white pushes a pawn forward and this is
a clearance sacrifice the White Queen
next will come to the back Rank and trap
the black king for example Queen takes
Pawn preventing white from promoting and
this would be a devastating killer blow
a beautiful tactic there from Jordan van
Forrest and an example of what he's
capable of
Jordan one for us can he surprise us all
by making a comeback in his match
against Magnus Carlsen and uh Danny even
though Magnus won that game it was a
draw for most part of it and that's a
big takeaway that's a positive point for
Jordan I think you have to focus on the
positive right one game at a time keep
yourself in a mindset that you can play
chess with think like a goldfish right a
short-term memory loss and just focus on
the next game but it's also hard when
you lost against one A6
yeah I mean 186 is a really tough move
to lose to and I I'm wondering why
Magnus is playing this regularly and do
you reckon it might be in honor of the
the late Mike Bassman who passed away
quite recently in English International
master who used to love playing 186 so
it's it's nicely because he does a lot
of things for a reason you know Magnus
he always has a reason for playing a
certain opening it seems so it could be
for that but uh we're back in with the
action now we're back in with the action
Magnus employing 186 we saw him do that
in title Tuesday as well against Hikaru
Nakamura playing 1866 and then crushing
it Karu he takes the first game playing
one A6 in the aim chess rapid and here
we've got a much more sane opening David
a much more sane opening it's one of the
main lines these days of the Berlin
defense not the Berlin end game Queens
are still on the board here but it is
almost symmetrical to pawn structure and
this tends to lead to very level
positions white however does have a bit
more space for now and easier
development and Magnus tends to light
these positions uh so we'll see it's a
bit of a surprise to me that he went
down this line uh actually when he's
fighting someone wounded now like Jordan
but maybe he's just trying to say okay
you're not going to win this game and
it's funny I was going to say the
opposite I was going to say I'm
surprised that Jordan allows a position
where to me this is magnus's game where
it's a position of of three results but
it's safe and and he can keep playing
chess forever right it's it's obviously
symmetrical it has all the Berlin jokes
insert every Berlin draw joke but Magnus
is already up a game he's not going to
take any huge risks in a structure like
this so so I I was surprised to see it
but for reasons that disagreed with you
David I was thinking that maybe Jordan
Jordan should be looking to spice it up
a little more but maybe it goes back to
the old adage stop the bleeding don't
lose two in a row Simon yeah yeah I mean
if you lose two in a row I mean it's
just a disaster and I think Jordan is
sort of uh developing as a player I
think in the old days Jordan would have
come out and done something very very
risky but um he's growing up and maybe
maturing by playing to Berlin but he's
got uh he's got to win with the black
pieces to to get back into this match at
some point uh that that is the problem
um so it looks fairly even at the moment
I mean uh not much going on here I'd say
uh chess wise very symmetrical position
you've got that skeleton all the pawns
are basically looking at each other so
then you look at the pieces and you try
to work out who's got the better pieces
when when the pawn structure is
symmetrical yeah it's a Berlin I was
gonna get in with the Berlin joke but
then I thought it might get too
repetitive so I didn't I stole your
thunder by accident I didn't I didn't
mean to but there you go this one will
of course be a long strategic fight
meanwhile action is getting started in
the second game between Fabiano Carolina
and itri Saga now the first fight
between them ended in a draw but it was
fireworks we saw early sacrifices there
and somehow iterizaga getting a good
position David Fabi seemed to survive
that one yeah actually this game the
previous game between these two ended
quite abruptly yeah the players decided
to repeat and it was actually a tourism
who could have played on who had an
objective advantage and it maybe is a
sign of respect to Fabiano but Danny do
you think this will come back to
haunting materials I want to ask you
that I mean you're you're a super strong
Grand Master I don't know if you know
that you're a very strong Grand Master
and when you're in a position where you
have an edge is black maybe you didn't
expect that coming in against a guy like
Fabiano what is the mindset there
because there's a match are you thinking
I'm going to accept a draw because I
don't I don't think we can stay away
from criticizing each saga's decision he
was better and had an opportunity to
play and he didn't so would you say it's
a mistake having been in a position like
that again against a player like Bobby
yeah I've done both things actually I've
taken draws in positions of strength
when I shouldn't really but I've also
fought on when I should be uh maybe a
bit more objective and I think the chess
goes do punish you if you don't take
your chances or if you don't show
ambition to the opponent Fabiano now
psychologically he'll think okay he's
slightly scared of me if he can't beat
me from here then or if he doesn't try
to beat me from here but what about the
chest guards punishing someone for being
too ambitious and playing overly
aggressive at every game they ever play
I'm asking for a friend
well the thing is I mean if you put it
the other way around I mean would
Fabiano have ever agreed a draw in that
position and the answer is no and that's
why Fabiano is fighting for the world
championships and one of the best
players in the world so I I think it was
a mistake you know you get a chance to
win you've got to take him um against
someone so strong no matter what color
you have
meanwhile it is a branch of the Queen's
Gambit it's the Catalan opening here and
uh Fabiano he has taken a Pawn on C4
Black's gonna be a pawn up for a while
he's going to try and cling on to it but
uh White here of course has great
development great compensation for the
pawn still very well known position
early stages
and that last move by Fabi it hints at
him wanting to keep that extra Pawn
alive the one that was just captured on
the board so it's going to be all about
the initiative and the compensation for
white for Eduardo terisaga but that's
exactly the kind of Chess that he likes
to play yeah he likes it he likes
aggressive double-edged positions we see
fobby plays A6 so he's still in his prep
at this point iterizaga I don't think
he's taking time here because he's
thrown off I think he's deciding how
aggressive do I want to be I mean there
are so many options here for white right
you can Castle you can play A4 so he's
choosing carefully just how spicy he
wants to make it and he's choosing Cafe
and Danny I'm still thinking about the
fact that you didn't get my Berlin and
repetition joke and I did get it oh you
did I did get it
I I did get it oh no but I I see what
you're saying I still and then I said I
still use 100 but I got the repetition
joke
um I'm aware no I'm aware of how
exciting it is to uh repeat repeat
someone talking about the Berlin so
um no I I did get it all right well we
are also getting more exciting news as
games are underway and Ottawa Wesley so
they're getting ready to make their
first moves there's not gonna be any
Berlin action in this one hopefully
David uh you never know it's Wesley so
now now we can repeat the same joke over
and over E4 drum roll please but we have
the most exciting opening of all time
he's doing it it's the most exciting
game you've jinxed it Tanya let's be
silent until the moment Bishop B5 don't
do it it's gonna be the most exciting
game ever but he's gonna put his Bishop
on C4 and he's Gonna Save Us all
yes hold on Wesley okay the Italian game
maximum tension promised yeah no quick
draws I think that also speaks to Wesley
feeling like he's the favorite in this
matchup again not trying to disparage in
any way but I think Wesley got a draw
with black and we've seen Wesley take
more Berlin draws than any of us want to
talk about like let's not talk about
that but the point is he does that for a
reason he has matched strategies at
times where he feels his chances are
better in Blitz or Armageddon right so
criticism or not there's a reason Wesley
is not going for it here I think he
feels like he's the stronger player
against Notre Beck and doesn't want to
let a chance with the white pieces go by
yeah this might be his chessable course
as well is it Bishop C4 I think he
recommends this and obviously he knows
uh lots of different types opening uh is
good I mean I hate the Berlin I've seen
this so many times now and uh I mean
Danny you're like a boss or something
can't you just ban the Berlin or say oh
you can't can't you just put a new law
out there we are actually about to have
a piece of tech live with a draw for
we'll be banned for certain tournaments
um and I won't say exactly what formats
we might be thinking about in the future
that prevent those types of things but
uh we will we will soon have a format on
chess.com where you're not allowed to
offer a draw yeah but you can still have
a repetition you can still have
repetition so it's you know there are
only so many ways you can avoid the
elephant the room and chess which is
there is a draw as a result like it or
not right but I think I think if you
look at a format um and if you look at
taking away draws later on I think we
can do our best to create exciting and
thrilling moments and then it's up to
the players to deliver can I can I also
say that the game uh with Fabi is seems
to be very interesting to me I was just
keeping a look at that and uh seems like
there's some real action happening there
so maybe we can look at that in a second
but
so far here yeah it was pretty quick
recap I think Simon will go around the
horn and check out all the games
meanwhile this one white has a slightly
fractured Pawn structure light squared
Bishops are off but white also has a
bind uh so both sides have reason to be
happy but uh Wesley I think has decent
chances and we're happy that this was
not a Berlin so this is going to be a
fun fight and we're also getting an
update that action is about to begin
between Lavon aronian and Vladimir
father said the first game ended
peacefully a fight that was and this one
starts with the King spawn opening and
please for the love of God no ball in
here as well
nothing nothing
but fighting Italian chess here levana
Ronin I think similarly feels like we
called we called this out before this
match began that we felt like LaVon
should maybe be the more well-prepared
player the more mature player I don't
know I mean okay like Federal save is
we're talking about him like he's a
spring chicken he's 28 years old and he
wins chess tournaments for a living so I
I don't think that he's getting himself
caught up in any surprises but Lavon
wants to show that he brought good prep
and by the way shout out to the air
quality there there you go Vladimir good
air quality yeah you were dissing his
room but uh quality is good right it's
got the window open at least and uh it's
strange that E4 uh this move will move
one it's always had a reputation of
being the more exciting move uh dating
back to like Bobby Fisher and Bobby
Fischer using it so well but uh even
nowadays that people say E4 Best Buy
test but um at top level surely D4 is
more exciting the Queen's Pawn because
of the Berlin quite a recent thing um
Danny you look at me like I'm mad there
been an E4 player uh yourself but I I
don't it's it's a trend isn't it I think
that there are also ways to avoid the
Berlin as white if you want to I mean
you I mean have you can play the ante
Berlin with D3 which in many cases gets
structures very similar right to what
we're seeing on the board here so I
would say I'm still a little E4 biased
obviously I play it but you're not wrong
that I I think there's a reason maybe D4
gets a little bit less preparation
yeah Berlin the Petrov the Marshall the
Italian there's too many too many
openings these days and the top players
they know all these little nuances the
Italian I must say is the most difficult
one for me both with white and with
black because there's so many different
move orders so many little different
details which change everything a bit
later on down the line
so that's why we see right now uh
fedexev just looking off to the side of
the camera he's not lost he's uh still
knows what to do of course but maybe
just wondering about move orders feels
like levon's left that white light
Square Bishop vulnerable to attack but
uh part of his plan clearly
yeah stuff maybe just using that
experience life I mean uh Lev is like
one of the most experienced players if
not the most experienced player uh in
this tour and maybe play more games than
anyone else so he's also an expert in
these E4 E5 openings and uh this is why
maybe he's going for a complex Italian
relying on lots of Maneuvers but this
exchange at night for light Square
Bishop I mean uh even I know who I'm not
an E4 player really even I know this is
supposed to be favorable for black right
black gets the two Bishops black gets
rid of White's very dangerous Bishop
um so it's it's interesting to see how
this will develop I mean at least I'm
going to learn something here why why
Lev has done this it's going to be a
slow strategic battle this one we will
check in with it meanwhile it is hard
action on the Fabiano caruana board
again the narrative continues of crazy
positions between these two
wow we need a while to unpack bringing
it up and I'm like
OMG there's a rook hanging on AA but he
doesn't even want to take it
the worst thing is I think I've seen
this position before
they're playing so fast this is this is
prep right this is this is a position
that's known
can we are we is it too early to dive
into analysis I'm sorry the selfish
person who wants to look at the chess
and see how we got here I think we have
to Danny and uh right now black is a
whole night and three pawns up but there
is a rook hanging in the corner uh if uh
wants to gobble up this Rook then maybe
now is the time to take it let's just do
a quick action replay let's backtrack a
few moments ago we saw this position
where black had a pin on this white
knight and a tourism said okay I don't
care take me I'm going to
take this lead in development I can
accelerate the play he castles and after
Bishop takes C3 this was the key move
after Queen takes D4 just giving a check
not being afraid to have to step back
here giving up the night as well and
okay we see Bishop F4 Queen F6 and not
taking this rook in the corner instead
taking on C7 this Rook is trapped anyway
that's the argument and after B4 Rook
takes B4 the players keep throwing wood
on the fire and they're still blissing I
want to give a shout out to Tanya though
because she kind of called it after Fabi
played A6 if you just quickly show the
position on move five there's a reason
that he turizaga if we go back to the
timestamp on just.com you can see he
paused for about almost a minute and a
half there because that he was making
the decision right here do I want to go
for this line and this was the position
where there's a reason we've seen Blitz
since then right he was like all right I
know Bobby knows this stuff but I'm
gonna go all in and everything after
this 95 is this very very forced
variation that leads to the the
complicated exchange Stacks we're seeing
on the board it doesn't only one player
who know who seems to be knowing what
he's doing because Fabiano Carana with
15 minutes on the clock more time than
what he started with and seven minutes
for it to rizaga that's gonna be a big
factor as the position continues to get
more complicated
yeah eight minutes extra a rook and a
pawn extra for now Simon you're the
attacker or the famed attacker Among Us
do you think what has enough
compensation here
um I mean this is just has to be fairy
right I mean we're talking about D4
being more exciting than E4 and I think
I think this is a good uh point to prove
it but I mean uh it's just a wild wild
position I mean at the moment if we just
count material white is a whole Rook
down
um but look at White's Bishops they're
just raking across the board Black's
King is stuck in the middle and um you
have to when if you're playing this way
as black you either have to be
completely mad not to have worked it out
theoretically or you have to really done
your homework and checked it and Fabiano
is the kind of character who would have
checked it with the best computers any
second so we'll find out soon and I'm
sure he thinks it's okay for black I
mean borderline has more time than he
started with so clearly Fabi knows what
he's doing in this line but I'll give a
shout out because even though he Tori
Saga did have several moments after that
where he took two and a half minutes and
a minute just looking back at it he
still has an equal position that is
still theory on the board and I often
say David that's funny in these games
when even if I'm taking more time than
my opponent as long as they're blitzing
that means I played the best move in
terms of prep right the momenturizaga
plays a move that makes Bobby think the
moment you go wait oh crap like did I
just play a bad move because clearly I'm
still playing engine prep or Bobby
wouldn't be blessing yeah your hot sinks
trust me when your opponent starts to
think in a line like this I once played
Fabiano I think we got to move 25 and I
was out of book and of course he kept
blitzing so I was happy until he stopped
and of course that was my big blunder
but yeah right now the stakes are pretty
high only five minutes left whole Rook
down how thin is the margin for error
here for a tourism if black gets one
move in castles for example if white
takes that Black Knight with his dark
Square Bishop on B8 black castles maybe
no more compensation yeah I mean I I
would be fearful if I was white hair
just because uh the way my opponent is
moving in and also the time situation I
mean I think you're completely right
though David if black gets castled
there's no danger I know we're spending
a lot of time on this game but I think
it deserves it it's exciting because I
think I think there's only one move here
for a white that prevents castling and
it's not taking the free night on B8 I
think it's Bishop E5 is the only
opportunity you sacrifice the bishop but
free up the line of your queen to hit C8
this would be the I mean okay the engine
agrees right now but if we back up I
think I would bet Bishop takes B8 black
castles and probably now black is better
so utilities continues to be in an only
must find only move situation and we'll
see if he finds Bishop E5 yeah key move
here key moment and uh maybe we can
check in with the computer to see
whether it confirms is there just one
move to keep the balance four minutes
and Ticking ten whole minutes down on
the clock
as Danny says Bishop to E5 only move
right now to keep the balance Bishop
takes B8 is the only other logical
alternative but that clearly doesn't do
the job it's such a nice position to be
in if you're Fabiano right because you
got the time advantage and you probably
know if my opponent plays the perfect
moves aren't going to be all right
anyway but if he makes one bad move I'm
going to take control and you've got the
black pieces so uh he looks pretty
relaxed you're talking about body
language Danny you are our body language
expert today Tanya's the body of the
year and uh what do you reckon does he
look comfortable Fabi I reckon he looks
he looks pretty chilled he always looks
pretty chilled he's a cool guy right
um but he's always got this book of it
so he always looks calm in comparison
right now especially you've got reasons
to be you've got 15 minutes on the clock
your opponent's time is sticking down to
three and a half minutes and this is a
difficult situation for iterizaga it's
also such a cool strategy about Fabi to
do this in a rapid format when you're
playing classical your opponent has
enough time to navigate through the
lines the variations but here the whole
idea is to get your opponent thinking
early on get him down on the seconds
before you strike yeah it makes me go
again go back to that moment you down
and say that even though itirizaga did
choose the spiciest of variations maybe
he shouldn't have really testing fabi's
prep you called it before this match
David is not a recipe that most people
choose against carwana and uh again
apparently there's a move that holds the
balance I think the only way is Bishop
but if you don't find it off the rails
quickly yeah the water bottle is that
that's always bad news when you're born
and takes a sip of water is that relaxed
it can't be good news for you what's the
theory uh you only take a sip of water
when you're winning that's like a like a
psychological theory that after you play
a good move you you take a sip of water
you put your pinky out
I love the pinky move that is awesome
and I think Bobby castles and now he's
happy and okay it was easy for us to say
with the evil engine bar and and and
kind of like just I could see Bishop B5
but it's hard not to take material when
you have a chance right it's sitting
there so he did try to get some of it
back but now we like black now he's got
to prove it now I mean he is the
exchange down the Bishops look good but
uh you know even without the evaluation
bar it just seems like black is pretty
safe okay there is a threat on the board
and that fret is a little bit annoying
puzzle Rush yeah you just gotta I mean
in chess you always look at your
opponent's last move and you ask
yourself what are they trying to do and
David what is white trying to do to
Black here you tell me Simon let's say I
play a great movie I push my Pawn with
black I might go for a bit of back
spanking here with Queen takes bishop
and there we go the back ranker comes in
with a Checkmate so yeah that's a nasty
a nasty move there but Rook to B6
prevents it and it's actually a fun one
to show because not because you're going
to meet Queen takes CA with booktake C8
but if Queen takes C8 you'll play Rook
takes B8 and you have this x-ray defense
where the pieces are communicating
through Enemy Lines there so
um a real quick tactic to point out full
back crank protection here Rook B6
really nice move from Fabi and the
problem is if you're forced on the
defense if you have to step back with
your Bishop uh as white then suddenly
Black's Bishop comes to life as well and
black is just a whole Rook for Bishop up
no problems at all just material
mathematical Advantage here
this this is how you draw it up if
you're fobby right you draw it up with a
huge time Advantage your opponent about
to get under 90 seconds on the clock
you're winning on the board this is why
Mr caruana has seen himself as one of
the last two men standing several times
throughout this season and he looks to
be on track here early on
and Fabi with that first 30 second think
once Eduardo did pick up that night and
what do you guys think is Fabi fullyever
that Eduardo has gone wrong and this
could be in the back for him
I'm pretty sure he is I would say yes
just because the preparation was
indicative of of him having this
position prepared so deeply right
probably if you ask him afterwards he'll
say yeah if he plays the Right Moves
it's a 37 move draw that's you know what
I mean but that's not what happens often
in Rapid chess as you pointed out Tanya
a great practical choice and and Bobby
is uh doing well yeah it's working out
well for him uh let's check back in if
Fabi manages to convert this we will
come back to this one but also let's
check back with uh the Wesley so Abdul
satra of game as that one also heats up
yeah this one uh is heating up we've
seen a few peace trades and meanwhile it
looks like white Wesley sohia is trying
to kick-start a King side attack whites
Queen Knight dot Square Bishop looking
really menacingly placed whites Rook on
the third rank ready to swing at some
point but black solid for now Simon
again I'm going to defer to you here is
White's uh well our White's attacking
chances
um I'd certainly prefer to be white here
I mean just because you got some holes
around the black king you can try to
infiltrate in and you see that White's
Bishop has gone straight into one of
those holes uh you're probably gonna
have to use your your favorite pawn and
we all know what my favorite Pawn is
here go Harry go Harry and that little
guy on the right hand side might have to
move his way up to sort of jab away at
Black's King side
um and uh this Rook maneuver you point
out Dave was quite nice I mean another
slight danger here might be Black's
Queen side uh this is this is a
technique that the top players use a lot
you know they switch sides they create
weaknesses on one side of the bar or the
board and then they come back all of a
sudden when they stretch their
opponent's defenses to defend so even
though the evaluation bar thinks it's
fairly even I would not like to be black
I mean black is solid David as you said
but
um it doesn't look good Dan he really
does it this position I'm with you and I
love how you pointed out Rook C3 uh
principle of two weaknesses right even
just from a practical point of view and
Rapid chess we look at the clock Wesley
is down a little bit but keeping
pressure on both sides of the board just
increases the chances your opponent
might blunder and Bishop E3 has an
interesting threat like will you play
Knight H6 check next and that would
force black to part ways with the dark
Square Bishop if you don't find another
way to defend F7 so I was looking at at
Bishop B3 or even all the way back to C1
and I like this idea I also like your
point about sliding the H Pawn up
although I'm a little thrown off that so
it's after Dirty Harry and not a boy
wizard
no well I mean uh
it was Dirty Harry for me that's what
did it you know it was always it was
always the boy about the pawns have we
got time do you want to hear my little
story I'll just tell you a couple of
them yeah okay so go ahead you got okay
Corona's about to win okay we'll go
we'll go g Pawn Gary that's after my
friends I don't really care now Freddy
the f porn Freddy Krueger you know
because he's scary when the F Pawn gets
rolling he can rip the position apart uh
and we'll just do one more for now the E
Pawn is Eddie after the famous Eddie the
eagle who was a ski jumper from England
who moved to Norway and was terrible at
ski jumping but he was the only ski
jumper we've ever had and um yeah maybe
people at home can just you know sadly
I'm even more intrigued now about why
the other one's her name but we're gonna
have to move up I actually am more
intrigued of the story for every Pawn
now but uh we see Queen H4 trying to
prevent the H Pawn from advancing and I
like that move because you not only
stopped the h-man from advancing you
stopped the other threat as well the
night jumping on to 86 so you control
all the dark squirrels
keeping it together keeping his King
safe for now and this is a good moment
to check in with Levon aronian taking on
federal as action there is also uh
on David with a queen Side Pawn Advance
Pawn Stars on the queen side the d-line
all the pressure building up and black
still struggling with the peace Harmony
here yeah I had to do a double take here
Tanya I had to do a quick count it's
level material but it doesn't feel that
way because White's pieces coordinate so
well whereas Black's pieces are kind of
just thrown all over the board here
Black's Night On The Edge there we saw
it with Jordan putting Knights on the
rim is very very dim and Black's night
not doing anything Black's Bishop on B8
the dark Square Bishop there stuck and
uh White's just completely undermining
the black pawn structure here feels like
Levon is just working his magic I love
it and I don't wanna I don't want to
pick on my my buddy next to me but I
when you first pointed out that Knight
takes B3 being a good exchange for black
right but in the division I wanted to
make a direct call out to the new school
of alpha zero the Leela neural Nets of
Chess because they're telling us no no
like all that matters again is is the
the ability to create the initiative and
in these modern lines of this Italian we
actually see this Knight take on B3 a
lot because of what we see e the queen
side lines basically can't be stopped
they will become open you'll have B4
which before threatened because the Rook
was undefended so it forces black to
keep the pawns on C6 and A6 I know I'm
getting you know a little too advanced
but I I think when you look at the
position white has pressure those
Bishops never find themselves and
clearly Levon has outprepared fedo save
a little bit in this Italian not just
Lebanon
with rizaga and did take the win home in
that last game but that was a Fabby show
start to finish yeah it was it we didn't
even get a chance to see the Finish it's
over a photo finish and iterizaga loses
a game that basically started in
Fabiano's kitchen like that game started
back at Fabiano's kitchen he's like
making some Ramen and he's pressing
space bar on the engine Bobby just won
that game at home
was that all prep you think David yeah I
mean his cooking's better than mine
that's all I can say impressive stuff
from Fabiano caruana and we talked about
the chess Gods iterizaga was punished
for not pushing that first game of the
day you're right yeah well fantasy of
here bushing his Central bonds what do
we make of this committal move here
desperation Simon what do we think yeah
it's the kind of move I'd probably play
because I get so frustrated you know if
my position starts to go wrong that I
want to try to create some action uh but
it it's either you know you've got a bad
position do you sit there and and know
that you've got a bad position and try
to defend passively well most most top
players um if they see it's gonna just
go worse and worse their position they
will try to create something they will
try to create a bit of mess at least on
the board and that's what FedEx is
trying to do here he's trying to create
a little bit of chaos by uh playing this
move but you know it it is losing a pawn
whoa what is this I did not see this
move wow I think you he was doing the
right thing and Simon you did talk about
black having the bishop here so you want
to open the position and D5 prepares to
do that but B5 is like uh hold the phone
actually if you it we got to go to the
analysis board we got to do it because
there's too many too many crazy things
to look at here wow that's
that's this one but Agnes Carlson big
update he might be taking his second win
of the day and once again a night in
Pawn end game oh my gosh wow neither po9
game look at those white Rook pawns we
talked about them the a H Pawn tonight
struggle to stop them you can only stop
them from one side and Magnus has two of
them the A5 Pawn is passed of course the
H6 Pawn might well promote just two
squares away later on black is
overstretched and I think black uh here
is just uh busted White's King is going
to be able to run across and stop any
black pawn pushers
what do we think here Simon Danny is
this over
it looks tough yeah I mean we talked
about this didn't we in the first game
you got the wing Pawn in the night
ending and they can be very strong it
didn't prove to be that way in the last
game but in this position is two squares
from queening and um White's Knight has
some brilliant squares it can anchor
itself onto uh yeah and you can see
Jordan I don't have to be a body body
expert there to work out yeah that he's
not happy head in the hands clear sign
uh he's uh he realizes What's Happening
Here one of the best parts about this
format is you have so many great players
saying playing so many great games one
of the worst Parts about this format is
you have so many great players playing
so many great games that we can't see
every moment and all I want to do is
back up right now as a kid and be like
how did Magnus do it again how did he
create this winning ending because I'm
sure it was super instructive again we
don't we don't need to do it but I'm
just it's uh it's awesome to see and
unfortunately at their next training
camp maybe instead of opening prep
Magnus needs to work on night end games
with his seconds or maybe not because
he's doing them so well is winning every
single game is this also a big nightmare
for Jordan just the fact that he loves a
knife I see what you did there yeah
that was good I like it but the fact
that he lost the first game in a similar
narrative and that's always hard to
overcome yeah
no it's just a master class from Magnus
you gotta say and uh Jordan moves this
King forward here I think it is level
material but the way to evaluate this is
you just take White's a Pawn off the
board and you take Black's Knight off
the board because that black knight is
paralyzed forever stopping that white a
pawn and the rest of the board white
will have a material advantage that's
why the evaluation Bar says completely
winning Magnus does just move his King
across Black's King can't roam too far
away either
because White's night will start
grabbing some pawns and here okay Knight
to A7 blockading what's the Breakthrough
there must be a way I mean do you bring
your king towards the left-hand side I
mean if I is white here uh you could try
to zigzag on the dart squares in you'd
have to come back first to do that
that's one idea just to support your
Pawn to dislodge your opponent's knight
uh so I'm looking at my pieces I'm
trying to create ways to to get in the
position with my pieces in the ending
the king obviously a very strong piece
uh I'm looking at my knight the other
other way as well and Danny I I have a
really concrete line here I'm wondering
can I play Knight d8 check and you have
to guard the F7 pawn and we just we have
to calculate Knight take C6 whether it
works or not yeah good idea
they always say that the Knight is a bit
of a donkey when it comes to stopping
past pawns and and this would be exactly
that scenario I while we have the
analysis board up I want to back up
quickly because the sad part about this
Titania's point about it being a
nightmare is just a few moves the the
blender actually just happened if we
back up a few moves before we joined
David it was literally okay looks like
that line is happening by the way it was
right here and Jordan could have played
94 to keep the night guarding the B7
Pawn Knight D6
and he just he just made the bad
decision of trading the bee Pawn for the
d-pawn instead he played Knight B5 and
it was so that was that was the sad part
is that it was just right before we
joined he just made a bad decision of
allowing Magnus to have this outside
passer
and now what we have on our live board
Magnus sacrificing the night for that
second Pawn are we expecting resignation
here by Jordan David
yeah I mean you might try a night jump a
night Fork a night check something but
none of it works white spawns one of
them's gonna become a queen in the next
two three moves but he's drinking water
doesn't that mean he's doing well
look at that he's got the water that's
actually juice because you're sort of
you need some electric lights because
you're losing you're losing all of your
sorry there you go it's got the juice
going but it's not a good juice that one
it's not a good juice You Gotta Give a
check and come back does that have any
juice in the position I see what we did
there Tanya again you're on fire Tanya
it's already the cringy pants
we'll let the people decide clean up the
bad jokes yeah completed the dad jokes
that's my job all right look at Magnus
shuffling to G3 which is a real killer
it's like I'm not even gonna walk my
king into any possible Forks resign
Junior it's over so it does look like
Magnus is gonna win this one go tunal up
if you were an odds maker what are the
chances that Jordan's gonna win the next
two one in a hundred
I mean against an on for Magnus I mean
it's gonna be I mean what's he gonna do
now I don't know how you can break
Magnus down he's on he's playing great
chess as well and another player who's
playing great chess right now is Levon
aronia dominating this position against
a Vladimir fellowship and once again it
comes down to the discordination in
Black's camp in Black's pieces David
that Bishop on B8 The Rook stuck on it
how bad is this for black this is
terrible Tanya and I think you
highlighted the uh key area of the ball
to look it's actually still Level
material but look at the evaluation bar
it's all the way in White's favor
because essentially black is playing
down a rook that Rook on A8 in the top
left hand corner it's stuck it's never
going to re-enter this game you need to
throw pawns out the way to get your
Bishop out the way to get that Rook
motoring but uh Levon knows he can now
switch the battle for the center to the
king side and he's starting to do that
now and uh there he'll simply have more
pieces again it's simple uh mathematics
here yeah especially when you look at
the clock it's not like love is down on
time you start to look one of the
practical ways this goes wrong Lavon is
also up on time
um you know there is a crazy world where
E4 happens and the bishop gets out and
we should remember that if the bishop
gets out from B8 The Rook can get out
right um so it's not like The Rook is
permanently trapped on A8
um and in time pressure blunders do
happen but but still not not disagreeing
with anyone that this is lavon's game to
win and you don't need a body language
expert to tell that fedesif does realize
just how bad this position is he does
line up the queen and the bishop but
it's hard to imagine a counter player on
the king side is there any hope of that
well I'm just seeing what Lev's going
for is it the water or is it something
else he just got something there
something what's he going for he's put
it back
that looks really great I could use a
stretch oh look at that the stretch that
is a confidence sign I mean it was
famously I remember Gary Kasparov he
used to wear a watch and um he you know
you take the watch off before the game
and it was it's very disconcerting for
his opponents because when he got a
winning position and he expected pretty
much told his opponent to resign he'd
put his watch back on yeah so you're
playing him and if you put his watch
back on you you basically had to resolve
respect him caught on camera where Gary
then took the watch back off
evaluated or maybe he blundered and
there was these great moments of if you
ever got Gary to take the watch back off
wow go down go down in history yeah yeah
I mean but look at the position we have
on the board here guys because you know
if white just puts the knight in the
middle of the board then black never
moved that Rook or the bishop
um and uh that would be very pretty
situation I mean sometimes you know
there's a lot of Art in chess and and
you can get art from beautiful tactics
but sometimes you know as you said David
this is not even a material advantage
here it can be nice positional ideas
that create a very strong impression and
uh
um yeah I mean everything's just bad
here isn't it for black basically I just
want to say it looks like photos going
fedexed off the board
tan yeah we're just on fire FedEx where
are you getting these from
Wow I'll stop no please keep going I'm
actually surprised that black didn't
play E4 when he had a chance by the way
I think Levon is not going to miss a
second chance to play 94. I'm not saying
that federal state was back in the game
but just like from uh
just from a breathability perspective of
the position speaking of air quality
like you got to play E4 and give your
Bishop a chance and just do something
but now Lavon maybe he should have
played 94 before King G2 but he doesn't
miss it the second time that pawn on E5
will stay that Bishop on B8 will
therefore be stuck and uh and it is over
yeah let's just show that Danny uh
strategically winning is how the top
players like to Define it and yeah now
these pawns actually get in the way of
that black Bishop it was better to throw
it away and at least pray that uh you'd
have some compensation I think the
killer blow here is that after Bishop
takes born the white Rook will finally
swing across we talked about this a long
long time ago and uh the black king will
be doomed as well if you could teleport
this bishop and Rook somehow over to the
king side to all the center put the
bishop on F4 it's a different game okay
not right now the G4 Bishop thingy but
you're right yeah it reminds me of the
game I think that was played on
chess.com in the last couple of days and
it was by Grandmaster David smurd and I
don't know if anyone saw that that tweet
the Aussie it was the Aussie uh smerden
and it was a beautiful game but it was a
situation where his one night kept all
of Black's Queen side pieces from
escaping and it's similar here that one
night on the left-hand side combined
with the pawn just really stops the rook
and the bishop moving and it's uh
beautiful yeah David yeah and I just
want to shout out to Fabiano caruano who
is joining us on Twitch and he says
Black's position is great if you add
another Rook on E8 duh yeah basically
then it would be level material and then
it would be a fight but uh right now it
looks like Levon is about to wrap this
up his last move Rook H5 he's cashing in
now
I better say I was having to perform
some uh real uh tightrope walking just
to survive but it looks like white will
win yeah I was a fine resource there
finding the Rook to defend the pawn so
that black white actually captures it
White's Rook is hanging yeah I might as
well I think he's just getting sick of
his Rook so he just wants to give him
away he's like I just don't like these
pieces anymore I have them and uh I mean
we saw Lev doing his sort of stretching
when he's winning and uh I'd like to
hear like any little tells that people
have when they're winning Gary Kasparov
putting his watch back on David have you
got any little tells I mean that you do
when you're winning do you think or
Danny it was a past life last time I was
winning so I can't even we'll let David
answer that one yeah I don't know I just
try and keep a poker face uh either way
I just find it's better not to get
dragged into the mind game so I'm trying
to think you're the expert on Hikaru
faces Danny I do know a lot of the
Hikaru hotels
um but well unfortunately Hikaru is
missing from this tournament we're all
bummed about that but you know next time
we have him on camera we'll uh
we'll we'll do our our full Hikaru
Nakamura dialogue deal
um meanwhile fighting fedisev he's
dropped a knight in on F4 that night
might just be removed by this uh White
Bishop sitting on C1 but at least the
game is still alive for now what do we
think of fabi's wisdom a moment ago in
the twitch chat being upper rookers but
it's better than that I saw his last
comment which even though it's not on
screen his last column was now at this
point an extra Rook wouldn't even matter
um so the the wisdom continues at this
point yeah as he says an extra look what
extra Rook wouldn't even help but uh the
fellowship's hanging on he's making a
move at a time Knight jumps in attacking
the queen and the Rook is white forced
to trade the bishop with the Knight and
if so why is left thinking right now can
he not just I'm trying to calculate here
can he not just win a rook on the spot
uh let's jump in left is calculating
he's got three and a half minutes so
plenty of time but uh why can't he just
take the Rook yeah firstly you can yeah
just take the Knight first maybe if Rook
takes Bishop then white simply wins the
queen on the G file and yeah like you
say Danny if Pawn takes for example you
can take this Rook Queen takes walks
into a nasty night Fork we call that a
forking problem where I'm from that's a
forking problem and it's only possible
because of federal saves last move
Knight F4 so it was a good good I spy
there David that Knight F4 walked into
that and uh he found a way to stay alive
so G takes F4 was the move I had missed
that is the pin and there's a pin yeah
it's a little tricky stuff but the
trouble continues he lines up on the H
line now Levon so threatening some
checks on the back crank and it all
comes down to the queen size all the
action on the king side but just how
Labs spawn on B6 on the queen side is
tying down all of Black's forces there
Tanya you know what black should do here
just resign definitely you just resigned
there is a time there's nothing else to
do there is the time put yourself out
the misery just just don't move in the
position and look at him he needs to
resign there's nothing else to do here
and um
freeing the D6 Square another forking
problem that black has to deal with
Knight to D6 check wins the queen
everybody
and that will be a resignation I'm gonna
I'm gonna agree with you on that Simon
yeah his time now definitely it's the
happiest the black Rook on A8 has been
all game but unfortunately
okay we we have one other game that
we'll be going to I mean we can stay
here for the final oh wait hold on no
resigns Brooke takes G4 check I'm gonna
stick to this one 15 seconds for photos
yeah he gives up the queen
well dropping anyway he's he's getting
the night will come to C4 and that's the
problem E5 is problems more more
problems plus with the A6 Pawn falling
next the white Rook will join the fight
so plus an extra Queen for what yeah I
mean
yeah
we'll find out to pick on the guy but no
it's it's definitely
definitely a big loss this this one is
not overall this is pretty loves having
fun here yeah yeah and that's it finally
taking a really nice tactical win there
and we've got Wesley against Abdul satra
fighting a King Pawn end game right
right as we join I think this one will
also be ending in a draw unfortunately
there were Rooks on the board a moment
ago but there really are no
breakthroughs so Shuffle Puck and uh and
that'll put the second round in the
books I'm guessing yeah and it's a rare
case of one side being up opponent in
the king opponent game but not uh being
able to win that's just because it's so
blocked yeah so there we go they both
tried but it was a draw yeah wow we're
nowhere in a father King that last one
does end in a draw we had such a
fantastic game there by La bonaroni and
quite a tactical Masterpiece it's gonna
be hard to pick one moment but David is
there something that catches your
attention take us through the big one
yeah the move actually of the round for
me was by Levon aronian and it was when
he played this really unexpected move B5
uh this Pawn break just breaking through
now and showing that Black's pieces
aren't able to support their pawns B5
utilizing of course a pin along the a
file black cannot capture with the a
pawn if he had captured with the c Pawn
instead then white re-establishes two
strong Pawns in the center and these are
gonna be Killers they'll cost black at
least a whole bishop and uh instead for
to say I've had to just continue
advancing but this is how we saw that
Dynamic begin of the blackrook and
Bishop just being totally stuck and as
we saw Levon brought this home to
Victory
what a game that was by Lavon aronian
let's take a look at our score line
before we head over to game three action
and we had two wins two fantastic wins
in this round Magnus Carlsen uh taking
the lead with a big margin two points
there and Fabiano caruana also won his
game against Eduardo trizaga and of
course lebanaronun with a fantastic
attacking Masterpiece there taking down
Vladimir Fellowship meanwhile not the
back of the Statue of and Wesley so
keeping it peaceful so that score line
is level and we will have more from the
aim chess rapid right after the shot
twitch break
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
this is your chance to build your
community find your local group or take
the lead go visit meetup.com
chess and yeah build your chess
Community it's gonna be a lot of fun as
the action does continue in the aim
chess rapid and we've been focusing on
division one meanwhile big results and
updates coming in from the other two
divisions Katie's joining us Katie You
Had Your Eyes on amitabatabai versus uh
kovalenko what's going on there Tanya it
has been incredible games in second and
third division had winning position at
the beginning and also a lot of time on
the clock he tried so hard and he lost
the first game then he had to come in
the second game and he managed to do
that with black pieces and I can see
that he actually won another game by the
time I was walking here in the studio so
he's letting now the mat he was the
favorite in this group and he is keeping
the leads in the second division but
actually a lot of action is happening
also in the third division as we
expected here Vladimir chroming won the
match against matches bluebomb with one
and a half to half he played the amazing
game he second game especially he won
the piece in the middle of the center
then bluebomb decided to give up another
piece in the Rook for still made ideas
but he had too many pieces to give away
managed to Checkmate his King another
big result is that fresenal won against
Eliana this game the match was very
interesting they had two draws but the
third game was in favor of fresna and he
qualifies to the next stage wow that
sounds awesome Katie so much has action
thanks for checking in with us we will
uh keep getting back all the updates
that you have for us and of course the
other two divisions the actions the
games you can follow it all on chess
dojo's Channel but right now it's back
to division one as the players are
looking for the big comeback here Jordan
banford is down by two points that's
gonna be a tough one up against Magnus
Carlson fantasya meanwhile after losing
getting crushed in that game where are
we expecting The Comebacks in this next
round three Danny I think Simon said it
right it's hard to predict a comeback
for Jordan but I think the other matches
are are still quite close I think
guitorizaga will uh
try to avoid deep preparation by Fabiano
next time so that'll be one in federal
save now gets the white pieces so if you
had to pick one of those two match-ups
or both Federal save Andy turizaga are
trailing by a point I think that'll say
of getting white probably has the the
better chances to turn things around
is best chest that we've been seeing
from him David this entire last month
exactly especially the kind of the best
speeches we've seen it when World titles
in Rapid and Blitz but right now he's
just Unstoppable people are barely
scoring against him in Blitz and rapid
and you've got to feel for Jordan he's
been close both times to making a draw
but just not close enough and Magnus
just seems to have that extra Edge yeah
he's just incredible at the moment
Magnus I mean Magnus when he gets going
um he's just better than everyone else
and uh what what's more impressive about
that is that you know the the Gap at the
top now with the elite players is
becoming less and less but Magna still
has that little bit you know so it's uh
yeah incredible earlier apparently a
rough Norway chess was all he needed I
guess to to wake up after after a Norway
chess it's been all Magnus Carlson yeah
because that was really up and down for
him Norwich has also the global chess
League where he had mixed results but
then title Tuesday and winning the grand
Chester nine out of nine and today again
winning both his games he's making it a
bit of a habit here winning all his
games in a day that can't be pleasant
for the opponents at all I think we have
to make a prediction will we see one A6
again from
pretty good
yeah you still played it just in time
that Magnus played against in that title
Tuesday that he won with 11 out of 11.
it's it's interesting I mean I know it's
we'll we'll ask Magnus if we get a
chance to talk to him why why he's
playing it if there is if there is a nod
um to the late International Master but
there's also some some points to it it's
flexible obviously it's going to throw
off your opponent they're not going to
be deeply prepared and when you believe
in your skills as much as Magnus Carlson
does he's uh he's ready for a game and
this definitely creates that scenario
yeah provocative stuff and uh often that
is a bit annoying for the opponents but
uh the reason it surprises me is he only
needs a draw Magnus to confirm his place
just can kind of confirm progress in the
tournament but yeah not playing for that
draw he wants all the wins it's amazing
how he can also kind of waste a move of
the a pawn and then he wastes another
move with a c Pawn you know he's wasted
like two moves in the opening and again
it goes back to like you want to show
children how to play chess don't show
him this game it's like you know they'd
be like well Magnus moves the same Pawn
so many times it's like no don't play
like that you have to be very special in
order to play like this and I think it's
like uh anyone if you if you're a master
of music you need to know the rules to
be able to break the rules and uh
there's not many people who can do that
I love that we're seeing the same idea
because we didn't have a chance to talk
about it in the first game where Magnus
was black but this is one of the most
principled reasons for the A6 move
you're going to bring this historically
bad Bishop in this structure to the B5
square and offer an exchange and he
Magnus did this in the first game if
you're just joining us where have you
been you can back up and check it out he
already won with black in a similar
structure and that is a very principled
idea right you're getting rid of your
worst piece within the upon structure
and so regardless of the time it took to
get here it's not like you're really
putting yourself on that much of a back
foot so anyway interesting stuff very
interesting stuff Magnus Hill with some
crazy opening ideas and they seem to be
working really well for him and the
other player who show an impressive
opening prep to their Fabiano caruana
he's about to start his uh round three
against etherizaga now game two was a
Crush by Fabi but it was a big part of
the prep so for iterizaka it's not that
bad of a news when you know that it's
not like you got outplayed you were just
out prepared
yeah I don't even know which feels worse
sometimes um but um you're right that
again you have to keep yourself positive
so if you're looking for the right the
right sense of mindfulness if you're
eternity Saga you're like look I got
unlucky I chose a bad line right I
misstepped in terms of Fabiano's kitchen
I'll avoid the ramen next time Simon and
now I'm gonna just play another game and
forget that I lost that one because of
Home Cooking yeah you got it you got to
just move on haven't you as quickly as
you can and uh you're totally right
saying that but I I think it might be
that first game that's haunting and
maybe not the the loss but actually that
he didn't play on As David as David said
it's like uh uh the gods of Chess like
Karma basically it's coming back to
haunt you if you get a better position
you can't offer a draw it's as simple as
that uh because you're not going to get
many other chances and that just might
be a little niggle uh at the back of his
mind which could affect him now yeah we
see it constantly in interviews players
like oh but in game one I could have
done this it would have all been
different it's like yeah you could have
done that and uh you should have done
but should have done exactly you didn't
do it no so it's like yeah but meanwhile
this game it was another caricon defense
another exchange variation as we saw in
game one between these two but a
slightly different spin on it this time
uh certainly less forcing where Fabi we
saw earlier sacrificed The Exchange yeah
and now it's a result he's ready to
break in the center as black he doesn't
want a slow maneuvering game uh he wants
to be direct
actually right Bobby didn't want to go
for the same line didn't like the
position he got against the attorney
Saga um but anyway
um now we're in a more traditional
looking Carlsbad structure as you
pointed out right white has the majority
on the queen side black is trying for E5
potentially now
um wow and further Saga time is running
out he needs to find a way to level the
match while we've had decisive results
in all the matches one has been
extremely solid not a backup Decatur of
taking on Wesley so and no surprises
there both these players absolutely on
their top game very hard to win a game
it's been two draws in this one and not
in back the first one on our screen
heading hands there but Westy's missing
let the cat out
okay sometimes the cat crawls crawls up
and at his feet and he has to like open
the door to let the cat out I'm just
revealing fair play camera stuff we see
these things on all kinds of behind the
scene cameras and he doesn't want the
cat bothering him while he's playing so
good call Wesley prediction how long
will Wesley be away how long does it
normally take him to take the cat out
Danny not this long so he's uh maybe
he's doing something else too while he's
out but I can't really get that much of
an edge in terms of last minute prep at
this point it's D4 he's been here before
he's
it's incredible you know but at least
we're getting a good look at his door
you know we should which is lovely and
I'm just trying to see some books there
uh but yeah he's got to get to the board
soon you don't want to give away a big
time Advantage obviously and looks like
there may be something else going on as
far as text stuff or miscommunication so
there's going to be in a more in a board
game okay well either way we hope that
the cat is safe whether unless they let
the cat out or not
um and uh telling you yeah yeah I was
just gonna ask who let the cat out but
that would be a really bad one so
looking at what we have here 15 minutes
have
but we will get moves here but meanwhile
let's jump over to the other game where
action is on and we are about to get
moves from fantasy if he starts with the
white pieces now it's not just the
scoreline it's the way uh in which Levon
won that last game how difficult is it
for a player to kind of recover from
that with just such little time in
between games well it's it's funny I
would argue the same storyline should be
in his set in his head as you said that
he tourism should have which we didn't
give it as much credit because Fabiano's
preparation was so dominant and so deep
but I actually think that Lavon if we
look back at that game he gave up the
bishop for the nine and he played very
quickly to a dominant middle game
position so obviously at some point he
was on his own but Lavon I think was
extremely well prepared in that game and
I think Federal save might also say hey
I kind of got unlucky chose a bad line
let's just focus on the next one and uh
and forget about the past
yeah it was it was really interesting
that last game Danny because I mean I I
didn't understand that I hadn't seen it
and it shows you how things developed
theoretically wise and how computers
helped out and you you mentioned this is
a new idea or newish idea where you give
up your bishop and it completely crushed
feta seven maybe that's aronian using
that experience as well David you know
he's got more years he's got vast
experience in many different positions
and you've got to use your assets when
you're playing chess so and he did well
I was going to say earlier actually
Bobby Fischer would have been turning in
his grave if you told him he had to
trade off his light squared Bishop after
one E4 so early but that's modern chess
and uh very active play in Levon again
well prepared in this one it was an
attempt at the Berlin defense it was an
anti-berlin for the sake of trying to
keep pieces on the board but this last
move clearly has surprised him after
capturing Black's Pawn on D5 in the
center and really doesn't take back he's
just saying okay I want your light
squared Bishop this time and okay
there's tension white can maybe go upon
up in various positions but it will come
at the cost of the bishop and black is
Super Active with great central control
so uh again feather save not enjoying
the fact that he's been surprised yeah
in the opening it's it's a big question
and just looking specifically at A6 and
why is federal safe thinking I think
it's because with the exchange of D5
David the D3 Pawn is now the biggest
weakness and so A6 is putting a very big
question on the board which is if you go
to A4 with the bishop now I'm going to
capture on D5 and D3 comes Under Fire
right away and if you trade on C6 I
obviously will take back and I'm happy
that I've won the bishop pair in this
case I think it will turn out pretty
well for black because the position is
opening up so I'm uh I'm just looking at
why would Federal save be surprised I
think there's a big positional weakness
on D3 and he has to be very careful here
you know I must admit I have studied
this position before in the past from
the black side and I was very happy I
thought there were no issues uh if I
recall correctly in this position Danny
uh White should play the move d4 and
after trading off
uh yeah black Retreats I think you can
go actually back in either direction and
yes you'll be a pawn up with white but
Black's gonna get great central control
the bishop comes out you just have
fantastic activity you can take one Pawn
back anytime you want so this must be
what uh Levon has in mind for active
defense we know he's a great proponent
of the martial defense or the martial
attack and it looks like he's going for
something similar here
but uh yeah strange that for the safe is
spending so long this early our lab on
our Union up on the clock uh and there
we see a trade happen and we're also
getting an update that we do have a play
on this chair the cat has been let out
Wesley saw returns and we've also got a
lot of moves and once again a really
interesting opening battle where white
has sacrificed upon yeah why the
sacrifice the pawn this is uh another
Catalan opening we saw one earlier today
between itarizaga and caruana where
black grabbed a pawn grabbed all the
material and went on to win will we see
a repeat this is quite a well-known line
uh it's actually a line I've lost in as
black myself so I know the dangers
but yeah simply white has given up a
pawn and is happy to play in the center
and on the king side black meanwhile a
bit passive for now what are these
dangers David you got to tell us reveal
that big opening prep Oscar de van he
was the one who crushed me in this in
this position but uh meanwhile it's
simply that black struggles to move uh
here black cannot fight in the center
white is simply going to step forward
with E4 and D5 or even E4 and E5 and
this last move H4 does hint that the
White Knight might jump into G5 at some
point some uh Blitz attacks against the
black king potentially if you're not
careful and it's a bit difficult to
defend here oh develop even if you bring
your knight out for example then Knight
G5 is the killer blow because as
mentioned this is a Checkmate threat and
now suddenly it's the other Bishop that
drops off and blacks pieces are all
hanging so it's just difficult to even
find moves from my experience
Wesley let's give him the job finding
Moose for black shouldn't it be Wesley
playing the cat Alan oh my God nicely
done so that was just so cringe I should
see you later guys
I thought that was great scraping the
barrel down yeah that was really poor I
won't be doing that again so the prep is
great though David I love that and now
we see G6 to stop your exact idea of
Knight G5 so I I was also just glued to
the analysis there really helpful to uh
to see how dangerous the position is for
black and here goes Harry you're a
wizard sorry yeah sorry I won't have it
again oh yeah no you can you can call
him a wizard he's uh doing a good job
there probing away at blank's uh
kingside and and again this idea of
using this Pawn on the right hand side
we call him Harry the H porn though it
is quite a new idea um it's uh there's
not many things in chess that have
really changed but uh over the last
let's say 50 years but I I would say
this poor in advance is one of those
things that people have learned is is a
good a good idea and it just gets a nice
hold on Black's King side and um if you
can get a queen at some point later on
towards Black's King it's always going
to be a danger
but he rushed moving that pawn I mean
that that's a little bit strange because
uh that does
um limit White's options there Wesley
now also playing quite quick and uh
Simon I've always thought you're a man
ahead of your time are you for pushing
Harry the H Pawn for years and uh Alpha
zero did confirm that often it's a good
idea but I think it's with this in mind
often it's not actually to open up files
to trade off on G6 it's just to leave a
pawn there forever and either promote it
later on that white H1 or just keep the
black king caught in a cage
yeah I mean I always pushy H porn just
to take on G6 and check mate I never did
this so there's more luck than a skill
obviously but uh it's uh it's it's
certainly an idea that you know just
players at top level are playing much
more often nowadays yeah well not the
back up the satura putting pressure on
both sides of the board advancing with
Harry the H barn and what's it for the
air pan
that's the one Harry the h-man Harry the
apron they're marching down the board
building up the pressure the one player
who needs to also get the pressure on is
Jordan van Forest he's down by two
points against Magnus Carlton and
magnus's King is in the center what's
going on David well to me it looks
pretty safe that King uh at least having
that block structure in the middle of
the board changes everything don't try
this at home kids we've established this
Magnus is not a good role model uh with
his black openings today at least but
with this structure Black's King doesn't
face any attacks from any of the white
pieces so should be safe I still prefer
White's position I've got to say uh
Black's Knight on F5 slightly lacking
squares there White's pushing Harry the
H Pawn again but uh yeah looks solid for
now and I'll say for now because this
one could explode later Simon yeah I
totally agree I mean um it's it just
looks a bit weird for black here and I
think Jordan's done a much better job
than he did in that that first game with
the same opening because you really want
to keep the Queens on the board I think
uh in this kind of structure because uh
whose King is safer the white king is
safer it's nicely tucked away Black's
King might look safe but it is in the
middle of the board and okay we have
some more moves uh coming up there with
the the H Pawn pushing I mean did you
need to rush that I'm not sure uh but I
I agree I'd rather be white in this
position 100 but it was a nice idea
because now you have this H7 Pawn that
might just be taken I mean there's
there's not a lot of help coming for
Harry over there on H7 and I don't know
whether white plays Queen to D3 or queen
C2 right away but this is uh
this looks kind of scary for Magnus I
mean again I think I think initially the
king does look safe in the on D7 because
as you said David the position is closed
that's why you can break that rule but I
think a little bit of Magnus bias might
be like oh he was fine but actually
Jordan is doing the kind of thing you
would have to do if you were going to do
the improbable to get a comeback you
would just focus on the next game be
aggressive against this A6 Shenanigans
and this is the best position Jordan has
had in any of the three games
it's exactly what you need when you're
trailing Magnus and you mentioned an
interesting thing that Dania about the
Magnus bias when we're evaluating
positions we would look at this and any
other player playing Black we'd be like
this should be completely winning for
white if any other player was playing
black and they played A6 King D7 I'd be
like you are a patsa go back to Pat's
school get a coach look at some videos
just don't play like this but as it's
Magnus you have to be like it's
brilliant very inventive you know some
crazy ideas
let's be honest right I mean he's earned
bias by by the way he plays but uh and
that's a new pose we're seeing Magnus
looking over chill there Magnus is he
looks like he's not about to play high
stakes chess he looks like he's about to
Netflix and chill yeah almost not safe
for work right now yeah Magnus we got
kids watching this keep the camera where
it is everybody
um
no but seriously I think we do get a
little biased I think if you look at the
position
yes you have this a file for Magnus
David but you can't ever play before I
don't think because of A4
um although maybe then you would get B5
so actually right as I say that maybe
this is what manga should go for he gets
B5 and the opponent is pinned to The
Rook sorry accidentally getting very in
the weeds here because I'm I'm
fascinated by what can magnets do to get
counter played because if you don't have
something like this H7 is hanging and uh
and urine is in business still very slow
this this uh counter play though even if
you take this pull it simply recaptures
and meanwhile the king side might
collapse and okay uh I don't know just
uh to point out the other idea Danny
just simply white is going to go at some
point with Queen C2 or queen D3 for this
H Pawn it looks uh again strategically
winning for white but uh how can Magnus
cause some chaos he brings his root to
G8 how does that stop the idea Queen to
C2 maybe it's just the fact that this
white Rook cannot swing at the moment
because this A3 Pawn is a weakness uh
black will try and plug the holes for
example with Rook G6 and again look
shaky if white Retreats for example but
no immediate damage done for now and uh
maybe the black king will find safety
eventually in the corner
we've got moves instead he hits uh
Jordan's Rook forcing it to fall back
our eval bar doesn't approve it kind of
just clamps down the pieces the black
pieces on the king side and then you say
all this about Black's position but then
you take a look at Magnus and you just
don't understand what's going on
yeah it's chill I mean he's also got I
don't know what the boots are too sorry
I've been fascinated with are those Ugg
boots those are very furry and
comfortable socks I don't know it's
weird how our minds think alike Danny
it's a little bit worrying but I was
rather than looking at the chest I think
what's that on his feet is it Wesley
so's cow I don't know I mean right I
don't know it's very strange I mean uh
are they socks or are they ugged boots
this is the question look if you get if
this position were anyone else you were
right Tanya we would be just like white
is about to win you have Knight D3
coming C5 is a weakness white can play
A4 now that the Rooks have fully
committed to the king side you can play
A4 and and get rid of this A3 weakness
so I just I really like Jordan's
position again it would be an improbable
comeback he's down 2-0 to the number one
player in the world but this is how you
would draw it up yeah it's not over till
it's over when you're playing against
Magnus Carlson and Magnus needs only a
draw to wrap up the match and he's kind
of creating something on the king side
with the pawn Advance wow H5 do you
think he's going to put the boot in with
with this one Simon Harry is running H4
is coming the white king may be a Target
well he's got to try something hasn't he
he he's got to try to open up the
position and uh you know create chances
I mean the good thing about having a bad
position is you kind of don't have to
care as much because you're probably
going to lose anyway so you might as
well lose and style rather than just
like getting uh you know slowly sucked
you know away your energy going so this
is at least trying to push the pawn get
something towards the white king so I
kind of kind of like the idea here I
like this last couple of moves for black
it feels like Magnus kind of uh thinks
he can get away with anything right now
and if he gets away with this we're
gonna have to rethink everything we know
about Chess Jordan certainly Under
Pressure here
H5 wow okay he's going for the black
king potentially he's trying to open up
lines I'm not really seeing what that
threatens uh this last move A4 surely
black can just ignore that and play on
the other side of the board
this one suddenly double edged uh no
longer one-way traffic it's getting
spicy Magnus is pulling it off with
right as we said he all the Magnus can
do it and maybe he'll pull it off again
he's he's gonna after Brook A4 he'll
find safety with the queen and gain a
Tempo on D4 maybe and then H4 is coming
so it's it's suddenly
I don't know where it went wrong I mean
we'd have to sit here and have you know
a bunch of analysis tools at our
fingertips and even then it was hard to
understand the position
those boots suddenly do look like they
were made for walking right now BTS A4
and Jordan
you need something I don't see it that
black king looks too safe right now
I mean he is opening up lines
potentially where the black king is yeah
uh so that's one good thing I mean he
could take with a pawn here try to use
the open file uh that the pawns moved
away from the B file yeah so he's he's
trying to do something but Magnus is the
same idea on the other side so now black
has counter play and previously
blackhead and no counter play so it's
improved for Magnus definitely yeah in
Magnus plays H4 instantly look at that
ba4h4 he is not messing around and just
like that Magnus Carlson is better
how does he work it in his favor every
single time no matter how dodgy the
position looks
aesthetically and I think maybe just
having that relaxed State of Mind really
helps actually in Rapid chess
and kind of put the bird into your
opponent you're like you spend the time
worrying about this I'll just figure it
out on the Fly I'll calculate my way out
of trouble how many how many chairs does
he have as well
is that at least two chairs there you
know um it's at least one on the other
side as well I think there's three big
ones
three chairs that's got to be the
tiniest room that I've seen Magnus play
from usually it's as if a tornado just
hit in an absolute mess with Magnus here
doing just Magnus things he's not only
great at winning winning positions but
also getting out of trouble and being
able to create something out of worse
positions can he win this one we will
come back to this but we're getting a
big update from catty with some shocking
news from division two and three
that's right Tanya something incredible
happened in the division two where
Grandmaster matlokov beat it with only
three minutes to get white pieces
against 15 without no increment so
chesscom game coordinators asked him
double checked if he really beat it
three minutes and he agreed with that
the game was draw which means that he
lost the match but here's the
speculation guys the question to you do
you think that it was something that he
was hurried to maybe catch the flight or
he had something to do or he really
wanted to have these three minutes to
win the game with white pieces wow Kelly
that's a great question because three
minutes Simon that's crazy low in an
Armageddon that's insane that's a very
very risky bid
um
but did it pay off I kind of missed the
ending did it pay off you lost not lost
okay so it didn't pay off I guess um I
guess that answers the question it
wasn't a good idea whether you're trying
to catch a flight or not that's um
that's crazy that's I mean that's the
worst bid since vichy's bid and not to
call out my man vishy right but we all
knew that he like we wondered if he
misunderstood the time control when he
bid I think it was nine minutes last
year to 15 minutes in the chess.com
Global championship and ended up being
you know way down on the clock and with
no increment lost so that's a that's a
very very dangerous bid How Low Can You
Go is always the question when we talk
about bidding armageddon's but it turns
out as Katie mentioned that the
coordinators did confirm that he bit
three minutes and he said yes there's
got to be a difference we did the same
thing with Vichy by the way last year
the global Championship were like hey
are you sure you know that at the base
time is 15 minutes right not 10 minutes
but she's like I know and then he did it
and he lost and we're like
okay we did our best so how cool would
it be Simon David if we could actually
follow the players as they make debits
we need to install it definitely yeah
the thought process uh especially that
one time we saw Magnus just get inside
the head of Hikaru bid exactly one
second under just predict her car is Bid
out of nothing I mean stuff like that
it's uh yeah it's game changing and that
happened and Hikaru could never recover
from that that one second win on the
bidding Armageddon got him the game as
well yeah no it's actually I think a
fascinating part of it the bidding
Armageddon is like its own meta game and
I think the more we have events that
have this it's going to be really cool a
few a few years from now if we look at
the crystal ball because we're gonna
have years of data and years of
comparisons and it's going to be
interesting to see because I think we
will probably learn what the best
strategies are the more we see top
players do it and we're already learning
more and more about how they think about
their odds so it's interesting I mean
Danny we've got the boss here with us so
you can tell us are we ever gonna see
the bidding Armageddon as it happens the
thought process as the players bid 100
in fact we're
okay
put on the spot about where the live
finals were going to be but we are
announcing it on Wednesday and we're
trying to work in some different
elements that we can when all the
players are together you know things
that we've seen that you that you can do
when all the players are together so
having elements like that getting a
little bit more insight into their
thought process should be more to come
sorry if that wasn't teasing enough
that's gonna be fun
uh physician David it looks like it's
Magnus Magnuson who's having all the fun
now yeah Magnus with great air quality
great chair quality and uh it looks like
great posture great posture everything's
turning in its way hair quality
everything's going well yes
um can you wouldn't see him on the couch
I'm just wondering why they're playing I
mean you can't if he wants yeah some
players look because as soon as Magnus
got his legs out his play his position's
got a lot better I mean it it has really
improved hasn't it and um he's got his
Queen in he's got some pressure now on
the order's position and yeah he just
looks really relaxed you know maybe a
little bit too relaxed but uh Champion
Sports Simon Champions prize after it
can I can I shall I do that now yeah can
I get would you want to see that uh leg
no I I don't think anyone wants to see
future day when we wear shorts you know
business up top party down low if you
wear shorts you can lift up your leg I
don't wear shorts I don't wear anything
down there no um so uh yeah no but it's
it's strange I mean you've got to be
comfortable when you play and uh maybe
the viewers at home it seems like he's
in some still drawing class you know
have some pose but yeah it looks bad
doesn't it now for for Jordan not only
for Jordan but also for Wesley so there
has been a big moment in that game not
the back up to satra Wesley so Wesley so
gets the advantage actually so not a
back in trouble let's bring that up and
do a deep dive not a backup this outro
of taking on Wesley so so far the result
on that matchup has been level are we
going to see a decisive game this time
it does look likely in that one I think
we'll see a bunch of dramatic results in
this round but uh this is the current
position between uh abdusutorov and
Wesley so and if we do a quick count why
it's no longer just one Pawn down it's
two pawns and uh we look at Harry the H
porn that one right for the picking as
well it's trapped Behind Enemy Lines
it's not going to survive too much
longer this is a key moment however
because if white does get a move or two
maybe some hints of counter play but uh
it does feel like Wesley is on top of
this one I'm just looking at his play
it's been very powerful very clear and
trading off pieces as well has lessened
the pressure on Black's position looking
good yeah David I see Harry the H Bond
on that 86 Square I really want my queen
on G7 to give a Checkmate and I want to
ask you guys what happens if white
actually pushes that deep on trying to
clear up that diagonal how does black
counter that yeah I think the good thing
for Wesley is it's his move has black
that's a very good point yeah if not for
example let's make a random move let's
say I push my Pawn as you say Tania
pushing this one forward at least
there's a threat of Checkmate maybe
black could still react here by blocking
with the bishop uh still some diagonals
but definitely this idea in the air so
right now uh in the current game
position I wouldn't be surprised to see
Wesley kind of take a preemptive strike
against this idea of Landing a White
Queen here eventually I'm not sure how
he'd do that maybe using his Bishop
maybe you just bring the queen out
Simply gobble up this uh H6 born this
Intruder that looks like a lot of
options he is doing decently on the
clock as well so but the idea telling
you pointed out is is really the key
reason why the queen went to B2 right
because even if D5 doesn't happen it's
the thread of the queen going to G7 and
the B3 Pawn hanging that is keeping
notor back in this this game right
because if white regains B3 at the very
least from a practical perspective
Black's King is feeling the breeze the
longer the game goes right this Pawn on
H6 the pawn on E6 is weak so anyway I'm
just say even if even if the Checkmate
wasn't happening I I agree that the idea
is critical because black has to go out
of his way to win that pawn go ahead and
we're seeing this happen right now
because Wesley voluntarily allowed the
opening up of the diagonal and now we're
seeing some sacrifices and perhaps white
just picks up the bishop and there's the
Dark squat weaknesses for the rest of
the game that now black has to fight
yeah ideas like you said Tanya of maybe
sliding the queen back and in at some
point uh still Checkmate ideas on the
board also this night which I was about
to criticize as being the worst piece on
the board Suddenly It's coming back to
life and maybe now for example you bring
your knight forward and yes black is the
exchange up black has an extra Rook for
White's Bishop but
while we're here we have to back up
because this move we have the analysis
up this move by Wesley C5 I mean Tonya
was just like you know trying to think
of ways to manufacture pushing the depot
into Queen G7 and Wesley goes I'll just
play it for you here you go now you can
take a pawn with it so I think we got
caught up in the tactic but that was
just a blunder by Wesley I mean what a
what an awkward move to play
and go for this exchange stack I mean
it's easy for us to say but I I think
that this position has now become back
to a three Result One anyone could win
this yeah yeah and materialistic one
player who needs to win his game is
Jordan 1 Forest this one looks like uh
notteback is back in the game but let's
head over to Jordan versus Magnus says
Magnus is very close to wrapping up the
match
yeah Magnus close now he has won a pawn
uh that black Rook has really
infiltrated on the second rank now I'll
hang up White's King as well Black's
King the safer of the two we talked
about that we debated that earlier and
uh Jordan's counter play of pushing the
white Jeep on forward looks far far too
slow and Magnus can also bully him uh
bully Jordan here with the threat of
Queen traits King D7 he's uh classy
stuff we had to come back this is the
last chance to get Simon's take on the
chairs because after Magnus either wins
or draws this game we won't see Magnus
anymore for the rest of the day so Simon
thoughts the room well I mean I was
quite surprised when Tanya said earlier
oh it's the cleanest I've ever seen
Max's room because like if this is the
cleanest that Magnus room is how bad
does it get you know I mean there's a
towel over there there's like three
chairs there's microphones poking out I
mean like the guy's got enough money to
get cleaner or something I mean you know
he doesn't need to clean his own room
just get a cleaner in you know I'll go
and clean his room if he wants me to
anyway I'm sure loads of people would
love to clue David would you like to
clean his room no
we met some of them we were out in the
city on Saturday so I agree with you
Simon I mean
um but anyway no Magnus remember
everybody only needs a draw to eliminate
your Divine first at least from the the
main bracket right Jordan of course will
enter the losers bracket and can have a
chance to come back from there and he
needs a ride
stays up a pawn probably gonna push for
more
he's found a really clever way that
Magnus Carlsen of trading Queens last
move to White Knight could not go and
take the black queen because there was a
pin on the second rank so Jordan steps
his King up but okay no Queen's on the
board he wants to go for checkmate and
uh Jordan does have the weaker king for
now so why not maybe a repetition that's
all he needs and it's on the board yep
and shout out to the twitch comment
there he has the air the chair and the
Hair Fair Prime Time speaking to my
heart right there great comment Jordan
had a nightmare then it was a nightmare
and oh yeah Magnus Carlsen taking his
match against Jordan bonforest in a
crushing style wins two games
comfortably draws the third one with the
black pieces it's been a day of great
chess by the world number one and action
continues in this one where the H Pawn
eventually Falls the H Pawn does fall
that means that now black has a
advantage of the exchange and a pawn but
if you look at the quality of the pieces
we've been talking about hair hair
quality suddenly look at what tonight
beautiful piece quality piece White's
Queen has potential White has a past sea
Pawn blackstrokes don't make a great
impression right now and maybe again I'm
biased by the evaluation bar but I think
in Practical terms white has uh decent
chances to say the least no I mean I'm
biased by the fact that Wesley was
winning this position a few moves ago
and and in a dominant fashion I mean see
I'm just surprised that that was one of
those where some sort of hallucination
right going on with the move C5 because
I think from a practical perspective I
would greatly favor white here I know
the eval Bar says 50 50 but to me that
King in time pressure is going to face
tactics those Knights are frisky yeah
already threats yeah I totally agree
with Danny there I mean there is is it's
not always about the valuation bar it's
about how practical and easy the
position is to play and people forget
that when they're looking at these uh
positions you can get carried away just
looking at that thing on the side of the
bar going up and down but just ask
yourself which side would you rather be
and who's got the easier moves the white
king has this much better compact
protection but the black king those
bodyguards those pawns have drifted away
uh from saving it so the black king is
going to be a Target okay you've got the
extra Rook but that's uh that that
Knight is proving to be so strong so I'm
I'm agreeing with Danny which is uh this
is which is dangerous yeah
I know it is but I I definitely prefer
white here I mean you want to keep the
Queens on that's one thing you should be
trying to do though because uh oh that's
a nice trick as well uh that pawn
becoming dangerous I mean look it's
starting to look very dangerous to Black
this position it's done to look uh very
hairy indeed and okay he has to move his
King there were threats of night checks
in the air there's this awkward tension
between the Queens at least black has
protected his Queen here Wesley and uh
Abdus tour of is he going to continue
pushing his Pawn forward White Queen and
Rook slightly Loose as well so not
perfect coordination yet to go for an
attack but uh it feels like it's in the
air and you can see Abdus excitement
there just readjusting his pose leaning
into the camera his uh Spidey senses are
tingling and mine too I must admit it
feels like the white has a tactic just
where is it and remember long term black
is up on material probably winning so
you need something over the next few
moves
what could it be can you have to have a
nice defensive move there from Wesley
gotta say a minute up on the clock and
that could be a big thing as we get down
to the climax of this game and I said
I'll come down to that moment when
Wesley went with that c Pawn push the
big turnaround that we saw feels that
way but still a slice of moments I think
Yet to Come yeah I mean they're still
going the way Mutual time pressure
Mutual opportunities to blunder ahead
it's just it's hard not to be
uh hard not to be looking in the rear
view mirror about the blender because
Wesley was dominant but uh I'm also
looking at the carwana E turizaga game
I'm not sure we can go there because
remember if carwana wins that game that
match is also over so that's something
we should probably
keep an eye on because uh we we may not
be only Magnus who's uh who's walking
away
um we'll see we will jump to that as
soon as we can but this one so much
tension on the board the pins that we
were pointing out and now all the heavy
major pieces lined up on the D file that
might looking good for Abdul satrobe and
even though Wesley is the one who's got
the material advantage up in exchange is
it not a back who's pushing for the win
here it has to be neuterbread I think
the King open and the chances to win
back some material to you we have Knight
B6 which might just be a big trade but
we might just get an end game with with
Queens if if the fork happens oh wait in
fact Wesley decides I'm just gonna
I'm going to help simplify things here
and get rid of that pawn but notabreck
is not going to give up
and the one player who's not giving up
right now Fabiano caruana he is in a
dominating position one more time
against itri zaga if he wins this it's
match over yeah and uh we do a quick
count white is a pawn down but the
evaluation Bar says he's completely
winning and that's simply again because
of the quality of his pieces that might
be checkmating attacks against the black
king White's a pawn looks very dangerous
as well and Black's Bishop clearly
inferior to the White Knight
Abby still needs something he still
needs something to push this over the
edge to uh turn his Advantage into
something more tangible
so what do we think Simon do you see any
big breakthroughs here maybe the white
king coming forward the White Knight has
a few different tempting jumps yeah and
I agree I mean uh the just if you
compare the pieces I mean all three of
White's main pieces are are fantastic I
mean uh you're just pushing the pawn
that's gonna be a very useful Pawn uh it
might just become a queen very soon you
could either use your knight uh to come
over and support that pawn again and
maybe that's just the winning plan you
move the Knight you move the pawn the
Pawn's threatening to move in this
position again and uh it just looks
horrible uh it's been kind of a day of
nights hasn't it we have Magnus Carson
uh dominating with the Knights this game
the knights dominating uh aronian
dominating with the Knight as well so
we're there into the future you know
yeah I've always liked the knights you
know I like my like tricks as I'm sure
you know Danny but I I love how tricky
the knights are and David you
highlighted A7 I actually think Fabi
missed that I was also looking at it and
the reason is that if we go back quickly
A7 could have been played because if you
took it there was a fork on C8 and I
wonder if Bobby missed that so now that
he didn't go for that we're back in a
bit of a mess here A7 uh anyway so this
is this is high stakes because again
Magnus has already punched his ticket to
the next round Fabiano has an
opportunity to do it but he may he may
be missing chances although now that I
look at time as well ichirizaga oh my
gosh he made that last move with 1.2
seconds on the clock this is this is not
where you want to be yeah it's so
complicated white has so many options to
be ready to play your next move in three
or four seconds and to not be a blunder
that's uh gonna be incredibly difficult
for him but Fabi 50 seconds what can he
try he's missed some wins already yeah
uh Knight folks are so hard to spot it's
easy from the comfort of the studio but
where is the killer blow okay too but
he's just gone Brooke I think he could
have played Rook V8 Simon I think so he
ends up doing the same thing but uh
maybe he prefers his Knight here so he
can blockade the pawns and uh this is if
he can stop that beep on I'm assuming
he's winning but it's not so clear is it
it's not so clear that's a really nice
Roxy too because it stopped Knight C5
check that was threatening to fork and
win the pawn look at this he's keeping
the pressure alive this is uh yeah this
is unclear but it looks at I mean now
it's the black king and the black Rook
which kind of dominate with those pawns
as well so it's a bit of a turn around
and this is can the White Knight Fork
the king and Rook that's the question
but uh wow it's too complicated for me
now yeah it's far too complicated it's a
fork in the game because he either has
to give that Knight check bring the
white knight to B4 and maybe even take
that black Rook or Fabi has to try and
bail out somehow he's just walked into
this uh yeah this is double attacking
it's not every day you hesitate about
winning uh winning an exchange like this
but when you've got two past pawns oh
he's allowing to get a knight okay do
you have alt on oh he doesn't have
enough time you have to hold alt and get
a queen
degrees
doesn't know how to do it
nobody who played the
pre-moved oh my God you can see he's
smiling as well
as soon as it happened I knew it was the
case because you have to hold alt to get
a queen of the if you have Auto Queen on
you have to hold alt so that you can get
a knight so he literally played the auto
Queen Gambit right there wow wow and if
you make a queen you lose on the spot
and with that we're just seconds on the
clock iterizaga goes down and Fabiano
caruana takes the match and Danny ranch
with head in hands I never have Auto
Queen on for this reason I also lose a
lot of chess games in time scrambles but
the reason you have Auto Queen on I
don't know if we want to show it quickly
David is because normally you want to
get a queen 90 of the time but in this
case if you get a queen there's a skewer
on C8 and white just wins but if you
hold alt you can you can bring up the
peace palette which lets you choose
again that is how the chess.com server
works and if we want to complain about
that there's no reason to because you
just don't have to have Auto Queen on
but if you have Auto Queen on you have
to know the shortcut otherwise you can
lose games like this and we've seen it
before do you know the worst thing Danny
is uh I don't know how to make a noise
either in this position you hold down
Alt
and I think right now he's sitting there
trying to figure this out so it doesn't
happen again Betty had this one he could
have saved it but didn't manage to The
Perils of online chess and we've still
got action on and one more blacks King
is out in the open but with that beep on
advancing perhaps potential check mating
ideas is bestie so going for the win
suddenly going for the win whether he
gets it is another matter Queen and
games are so complicated uh the only
thing I know about Queen end games is
that nobody knows anything about Queen
end games it's just about dodging the
checks finding lucky squares for your
king and okay I've just sort of grabbed
a pawn in the evaluation bar reacts
is it time for Black's King to come in
he pushes the pawn you can give a check
and pick up pick up on demons
if he takes King H3 and there's me and
you can't fight against it abducatorov
didn't see it
another question
he reacts he's adjusting his camera he
knows this is the moment he's done it
yup the White Queen has to go and take
that black pawn of B2 or it has to move
and the black C8 no Cree G4 check and
it's over anyway
oh my God he created the crossfire check
with Queen G4
Wesley so tricky as ever we'll show this
classy stuff from Wesley he's going to
take the point and the lead
Queen end game so treacherous just one
slip and it's always over
You Gotta Give Wesley credit though in
there because he let this game get away
he blundered it away he kept his
composure we were predicting the
notorbeck right probably had the
Practical Chances with the Knight and
and hearing this queen ending he shows
his experience and uh tricks the
youngster
pretty awesome stuff to go for a mating
net on the king side and have that pass
Pawn Yeah beautiful geometry that from
Wesley and he gets the win with that
point
wow
um what a round by the way we didn't
even get a chance
with haronian right I mean I think that
game in a draw but what a what a game
what a realm
incredible turnarounds there and Magnus
and Fabi taking their matches in just
three games and then we saw Wesley so
taking the lead in his game lots of
topsy-turvy moments a total roller
coaster David what was the big moment
actually Tanya I'm going to quickly
highlight two brief moments and they
were from the two final games that we
did look at there just the closing
stages because they were so beautiful in
their different ways it was this moment
Abdul sotorov maybe could hold the draw
with accurate play here as white but uh
he let Wesley so strike by grabbing a
pawn and greed was not good because
after the pawn to B2 what he had missed
is that after the black queen blocks he
simply cannot take on B2 this would lead
to Checkmate it's inevitable here either
a Checkmate on the G2 square or if white
stops that a back rank Checkmate and
this was a beautiful movie been giving
Wesley so the win and finally I figured
out how to also promote to a knight
under promote to a knight and it's here
that this would have been the saving
move making a knight with black giving a
check and getting the Knight out the way
next move but of course he wasn't able
to do that and heartbreak fought into
razaka in the second on the plug on the
promotion was the name of the game but
it was hard to get it with just two
seconds and finally he did get flagged
let's take a look at our score line and
uh Fabiano garana Magnus Carlton already
booking their spot in the Winner's
bracket for the day meanwhile Vladimir
fedexev has to win on demand that final
game as does nordeback Abdul sattro
which one can we expect an Armageddon in
oh my gosh expecting an Armageddon is
always is always hard I guess
well no they both get the black pieces
so just going through the the opening
line that means that I'm I mean I'm
looking at both Lev and Wesley's big
favorites because they get white Wesley
will invite the Berlin draw this time
and you better not give it to him
because he'll take it
um and Lavon has just been so sharp so I
think both players have big uphill
climbs yeah what do you think well I
think their experience is really going
to help me because they can kind of
dictate what kind of openings to play
and they only need a draw so I'm with
you it's going to be really hard I mean
I'm guessing if anyone can come back
I'll go for fed
um because you know I've seen him do
this many times online before but it's
uh yeah it's going to be very tough now
yeah
it's going to be incredibly tough which
means a lot of fun for us again the
players strike back and we also had a
lot of fun when Magnus Carlton and David
Howell took the air things challenge
take a look
yeah that really just looks like you're
moving upon like a knight
is this actually work
you tell me I'm guessing I know you're
guessing just sometimes your guesses are
right and problem oh it's just a nice
way to lose the game
spotted my trap yeah Bishop D4 you know
he sees everything one thing is if they
play just this way but to watch this
must be
wow David what happened there that
looked like a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun but I'm pretty sure we all we both
played illegal moves there it was it was
a long game there was a massive crowd
actually and I was a bit nervous uh yeah
I won't reveal the result but it was fun
I was gonna say I I now I just want to
know what happened because I keep
looking at that position like is if
that's a Pawn on C2 for Magnus then
you're in trouble if it's not a pawn I
never mind I'm not gonna try to solve
the chess on that you know what I've got
to go I don't know the result but by the
look and David's face I I think David
got it we're gonna have to wait until
tomorrow oh look at that little little
rubber the hands there as well I think
he's giving it away but maybe I'm wrong
I don't know we have to find out soon
just revealed the result of his
challenge with Magnus Carlton we'll find
out tomorrow a bit for now we are being
joined by one of the winners of the day
it is Fabiano caruana who took his match
in three games Fabi welcome and
congratulations
thank you wrapping it up in three games
it felt like everything worked out today
what are you most pleased about you've
got a lot to choose from
well the uh the second game it was just
by pure fortune that I checked this line
a few days ago and not even for myself I
was checking for someone else and uh
then I thought why not why not play it
I've never played this line before and
I got a winning position without really
having to make a single move on my own
and uh yeah the third game I guess I
guess what happened is that he
uh had Auto Queen on that's the only
thing I can the only way I can explain
um
why he he ran out of time but he he was
defending really well in the third game
I mean it was very I thought it was
miraculous how down a piece I can't
really coordinate in time and I have to
go for this position with uh where he
under promotes tonight and I still
thought there's pretty decent winning
Chances with low time
because my king can try to run into the
center again but objectively I guess
he's holding and
uh and yeah I guess it's a bit of a
strange and unfortunate unfortunate end
but
uh this is why I always make sure in
Rapid games I always have my uh my other
queen turned off
I I'm really glad you said that Favi hey
there it's it's me it's me Danny um
you're looking fresh by the way
um but I'm really glad you said it's the
moment he took on C2 and and you allowed
it I was like he doesn't like he has
Auto Queen on and he doesn't know how to
turn it off like you could see the whole
thing happening we've seen it happen
before but all right good Pro tip to
turn it off I want to ask you man you've
had some pretty good events this year
you look you look like you're off to a
good start right no one wants to jinx
anything but how important how important
would it be for you to win one of these
rather than rely on the Grand Prix
points to punch your ticket to the live
final
yeah it would be it would be a great
personal success uh I I've been close a
few times but but haven't quite made it
I stumbled at the Finish Line twice
against Hikaru and against Notre Beck uh
especially against Hikaru was it was
felt really really close because we got
down to an Armageddon game and uh and so
that was a big disappointment but I'm
not going to get ahead of myself it's
still just the beginning of the
tournament and
um
like I I you know I came into this match
the first day
kind of like with not many expectations
because I I had to travel today I had to
get back in time for the maps that was
the first thing and it wasn't 100 clear
because my flight was also delayed and
um and I woke up at four in the morning
so I I was just really happy to get past
this match I was thinking that would
already be a really big success and I
guess Magnus is in the same position
because last night we were we were
having dinner together a lot of the
players Magnus was there and I guess he
also had to rush to to wherever he was
going to to make his match in time so
it's a very tight schedule I think we're
going to have to do this potentially
again for the next
um for the next event or whoever
qualifies because that's like scheduled
right I mean there's so many events this
year that's scheduled right after
another event so it's it's sometimes a
bit of a rush just to be able to make
these matches
uh hi Fabby and um you mentioned there
that uh you're out with dinner having
dinner with Magnus yesterday was there
any celebrations going on potentially
glass of wine or two
there were a few drinks but I think we
kept it pretty subdued because we I
guess we all had pretty early flights
and I I didn't want to be hungover on
top of on top of having to take an early
flight and getting no sleep so I decided
to to um to be a bit low-key and uh and
there was a bit of Celebration I think
Magnus was very happy after his
tournament Victory
um he seemed to be in good spirits
and um it was actually a great table
that we were at I mean there was a lot
of stories uh
so it was a fun night
come on the chessboard today as well
Fabi well done congratulations one more
time and we'll see you tomorrow
thanks see you tomorrow
raining U.S Champion Fabiano caruana
takes his match in just three games and
the other player to have done the same
is Magnus Carlton well number one and he
is joining us Magnus congratulations
thank you we just had Fabian and I have
to ask you the first question he did
mention that there were a couple of
celebrations last night before flying in
for this one can you confirm or deny
that
well I left for you earlier soon
uh
I don't know about that but
um
uh
sure I mean
didn't have some so much
time to do anything else
or the clients and get home to play
and uh Magnus you've been continuing
your good form from Zagreb into this
event uh how do you feel in general with
your play today
yeah I was pretty tired today so my
my play was not so so good but so I'm
honest to to eat out some some games
anyway uh but
um I I think Jordan also probably was
tired after
the Dutch championship and um
probably an emotional match yesterday
um and it seemed like he was missing
sharpness in the in the critical moments
really because
most of the time he was not thinking so
much uh and uh he only started thinking
after after he had made mistakes so I
think he was just not being grateful to
me
you know Magnus Favi just mentioned that
it's a tough schedule these days for
professional players so many
over-the-board events followed by these
online cycles and so it got me thinking
you and him were in a similar boat both
traveling we know that it may not be the
last time nor was it probably the first
how hard is it these days to be a
professional player when the schedule is
just so darn packed and what do you do
to uh to try to keep yourself fresh when
you're when you're on a plane early and
playing at events like this
well he had it easy I played two weeks
in Dubai before
I can desiregrave and you didn't so I'm
playing back to back to back
um
I don't know I I just
I I didn't do anything special today uh
I I mean I had to get up early at least
for well
for anyone's standards but especially
for me
um and then I just I was just hoping
that I would get through today and then
hopefully tomorrow I should be should be
back in goodship
so that Magnus and you have an early day
in the office
there are three games so get some rest
and we'll see you back in Action
tomorrow
yeah thank you
Magnus Carlsen takes his match as well
in just three games he wasn't very happy
with his games that was surprising
Magnus saying that he's a little
critical about his place I think I think
it was I think it was fair I mean the
truth is I think Jordan beat himself a
couple times
the H Pawn in one move with King D3 and
then we had an even worse night in game
where Jordan played this Knight to B5
move so I think Magnus like a lot of
great players is kind of always a little
overly critical of himself but I don't
think it's unfair I think he should be
happy but the win he should get some
rest because Jordan really I think
unfortunately beat himself today
I don't ride from Magnus with Dubai
fading to Zagreb and now straight into
the aim chest rap
s the job done in three games before the
other players action is still on as a
fantasy of an abductor of have to win
their fourth Game On Demand to force a
tie break there and we've got the
players there ready not everybody
looking fully focused on this one wow
that's a meditative pose right there
body language expert coming in either
either the camera's frozen or he's
meditating you know either one or is
possible
um but no it clearly he's uh he's not
frozen he's really getting himself in
the zone and you know you ask which
player should have the better chance of
a comeback
I kind of pleaded the fifth on that I
basically said I think both Federal save
and Notre back are in big trouble but I
think that notorbeck can focus from a
psychological perspective guys on the
fact that he had his chances in that
game right and it it blundered itself
away in the queen ending and those
things are very tricky so I think if you
can keep him so focused psychologically
he has a chance in this one
um and uh he does need a good opening we
know Wesley will take any possible
opportunity to simplify the game to take
all of the risk all of the sting out of
uh the position uh so okay a pause there
from update story of just briefly and he
goes for the Queen's Gambit declined uh
what do you think of this question
so hard nowadays with the black pieces
uh against someone like of Wesley's
strength to get a position which is just
Dynamic and uh I think you just got to
try to keep the pieces on the board
um I think the strategy to win a game is
you don't go too crazy keep the piece on
the ball keep some tension and just wait
until you get an opportunity hope you
get an opportunity uh Wesley going for
this exchange variation and this is as
you say one of the most classical porn
structures you can get and we often see
more exchanges coming up in this which
is uh there we go the Bishops now
getting exchanged as well and um where's
the opportunity to win gonna come from
the Berlin so at least you have that
right Wesley didn't play in an
opportunity to get a draw's weight he
didn't go for the Berlin so I feel like
we should all acknowledge that yeah that
might be because NADA bag might have
chosen the Sicilian and some attacking
ideas there but I have to say when
you're in a must win situation Wesley's
got to be the worst aborn interface
especially with the black pieces is just
such a tough opponent to beat I agree
totally his style is is we were talking
about this and whatever hangout sessions
we have obviously Magnus Carlson is the
best chess player in the world
I think Wesley so and in many ways is
makes the least amount of mistakes at
times I feel like Magnus wins more games
and he puts the pressure in the right
spots and in terms of getting those
close victories but Wesley doesn't lose
a lot of chess games and he doesn't beat
himself and and that makes the situation
even harder yeah Magnus is the one who
takes the most calculated risks the best
calculated risks Wesley for him the word
risk doesn't exist unless he really
needs it too and uh he's in that dream
scenario a draw is good enough and Rock
Solid for white but at least pieces are
on the board that's good news for
nordebec and another player who's in a
dream scenario is level
on demand and he goes for the Sicilian
the Cecil for the kill Let's Do It Let's
Do It allepin come on Lev no one wants
to see this guess who's paper opening
this is wow 25 C3 what a beautiful move
by the way I love Queen A5 as a response
to the elephant though because so many
of these C3 Sicilians do have
reputations as leading to some very
drawish variations and federal save
plays Queen A5 to make sure that it gets
spicy and he's trying to surprise left
very rarely plays so employs the alapin
uh I've already seen him push his point
to C3 against the Sicilian so okay at
least we'll get a game in this one too I
think Queen A5 is a stinky move for
terrible move but it looks like levon's
not trying to punish black directly he's
just saying okay I'll let you develop
normally I'm just going to get the white
king castled and uh yeah we'll see a
interesting little game with all pieces
left on the board yeah I mean C3 is a
very clever choice because uh as you
were saying so many of the variations
are just drawn and there's not much that
uh black can do but uh the setup we have
now this move that fed has played in
this position it's kind of like I think
you'd be quite happy actually yeah in
his chair he's like all right yeah I
mean honestly he plays D5 he's going to
get a position with a fight here so
obviously like you said David Queen A5
is is a stinky move a good adjective
there that's a PG appropriate for my
kids you know PG appropriate adjective
but I like Black's position at least
from the standpoint that he's gonna get
a fight gonna get an opportunity to play
for the must-win game that he has to
have yeah we should mention the black
queen lands on A5 don't try this at home
but the reason was it uh it's on the
same diagonal as the white king so there
are some pins there it's impossible for
white to occupy the full center with his
pawns it was not possible earlier to
play D4 and one go so there is a purpose
behind this slightly strange move yes
black will lose time dropping the queen
back later but at least he's gained
something gained a bit of time maybe uh
at least in uh kind of positioning the
pawns and there we go occupies as much
space as possible nice position for
black yeah this is fantasy of going for
it from the very start it's sort of more
determined by The Mad situation than
anything else he has to go all in and
that's exactly what he's doing with his
opening play right now yeah I mean why
don't players do this all the time
rather than play the Berlin this is the
question you've got to ask you know I
mean like he's got a very playable
position here it's very rare that you
get a space Advantage with the black
pieces and he's got a space advantage
and um he should be playing the Sicilian
more often you know um it's it's clear
not no more berlins I agree and if we
get an exchange on D5 we get one of
these maroxy buying boloslavski Hall
type structures and we're going to see
it right where black is going to have
the space Advantage with the E5 and C5
pawns and again okay like obviously
we're
sort of a little biased toward black
because we want to see a fight we want
the element of federal save having a
chance here I think Lavon is also in a
very solid position right um and it's
not like he expected the big fish to
roll over so uh so we'll have a fight
for sure
yeah and Levon has castled his King to
safety black has to decide how he's
going to develop his pieces uh yeah
White's done nothing wrong so White's
not going to be worse it's just the fact
that uh it is quite an exciting position
quite imbalanced position that's
pleasing us here in the studio
and okay we've only got two games it
just yeah I was gonna say we just had
all this drama and these these huge
moments of Auto Queen not being turned
on and now it's like oh we gotta we get
a calm little round here only two games
we're gonna get to dive into some chess
here and that was fun with Fabi uh
saying that this is exactly the reason
that he keeps his Auto promote to Queen
off yep that's uh a pro tip for everyone
at home when you switch because it's a
global Universal setting for any user on
chess.com it applies to all your games
and you always want it in Bull and Blitz
but he made a really good point to say
in Rapid I go out of my way and turn it
off and again this is the modern world
we are living in a global online chess
you know hybrid environment and I think
those types of things can pay dividends
and it's a practical thing that you have
to think about depending on the format
you're playing
admit mine isn't on what about you guys
Simon David I've got Auto promote to
Quinn on yes always have done no mine's
not on nope so far I need to that's
because you learn tips
if you get to that stage anyway you're
normally doing pretty well so you might
as well rub it in and get a night or two
or eight or so this is why Dave is a
much better chess player than both of us
he prefers Queens yeah
all right Bishop 5 has played this is
where the bishop belongs when it comes
to putting pressure on the D3 Pawn but
it also was inviting a little bit right
inviting some some attacking chances
yeah and I think this is uh very
specifically aimed against one of
White's ideas if we had seen for example
play a more traditional move let's go
back one if you played maybe bishop E7
then white could just destroy the center
immediately with D4 I think this is one
of the ideas you're alluding to Danny
and for example if everything comes off
at the very least white can play the
move Knight to B3 hit the queen force it
back next move take this pawn and we see
all of the center has disappeared it's
symmetrical most likely result right
it's going to be a draw and that's not
sufficient so Bishop F5 does say okay if
you push forward now at least I have the
option maybe after a trade of pushing
forward I'm not sure you want to take
this option but he's floating that idea
in levon's mind also perhaps you should
sure why I think of sorry if E4 is
played there's there's Knight H4 and
that's the that's the problem with not
playing Bishop E7 which is why I think
it's a cool thing to finish because that
was the trade-off right Federal save
chooses Bishop of five but allowing
Knight H4 at some point might backfire
so I think you're right David I think
we'll see D4 by the way anyway I think
D4 is great maybe I mean the black king
is stuck in the center it's going to
take two moves to Castle it safely and
this is the opportunity you've got to
take with white when your King's Castle
you've got to open up the center I mean
even if you only need a draw uh you've
got to play like you you're trying to
win the game that's also important so uh
this deform evil is quite scary for
black actually I mean uh
um D4 looked good but instead he played
Knight to H4 anyway attacking this
bishop and after the bishop steps back
Bishop to G4 so attacking without the
use of pawnbricks uh he's hoping for a
bishop trade and the White Queen gets
very active suddenly black cannot Castle
on the queen sides because uh C8 is
covered and you cannot move this bishop
because the White Queen is so active
attacking G7 interesting photo save
looks angry he looks angry about that
he's like you're taking away my chances
to keep this game interesting
all right he does exchange and go back
but
um
yeah it just feels like fantasy have had
this really fascinating opening approach
trying to gain space but now we see
white the king is Castle pieces are
coming out more free play the e-line is
open the Knight can jump to the center
of the board The Rook can shift one
square start targeting the black king
feels like the opening worked out for
Levon
it does now yeah I I agree as you were
saying everything I was nodding my head
off camera and I agree with you I think
this game is uh
starting to slip a direction that makes
it harder for black to come up with
chances so you know what he'd love to do
David just because you highlighted it or
finish that point is he would love to
Castle Queen side just get the Kings on
opposite sides of the board gives you
that practical chance of at least I can
throw everything in the kitchen sink in
a game that I absolutely have to win so
I think he'll try to orchestrate
something
somehow try and kick the White Queen
away and cuss up inside I mean you can
go G6 and maybe F5 yeah that's kind of a
useful plan to play something like that
to try and block uh the queen on that
side yeah and let's before we leave this
one let's let's also highlight that
Wildlife did take some of the air out of
the position and the light squares with
the bishop trade let's not forget the D3
is tender and that was the problem with
trading off that Bishop is white does
have a weak deep on so it's not like
this is that there weren't consequences
in terms of the choice Lev took and at
some point if there's a rook on the D
file watch out for that d-pawn because
D4 D4 is not happening anymore for what
yeah without Pawn breaks you might have
pretty pieces like white does here the
White Queen White Knights looking active
but they're not really hitting anything
and it takes them a while to break
through so fedisev big question for me
is will he offer to trade Queens
obviously you want to keep Queens on
when you need to win but uh here trading
Queens would at least get rid of some of
the pressure get rid of some of White's
active pieces for example Black's Queen
could slide one square to D7
what do we think of that it's one of
those situations where you have to play
the match and not the position as much
even if it means objectively a worse
alternative you want to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible here
right now and uh Simon do you agree do
you choose White I choose white here I
mean I just like King safety and uh
especially at this quicker time limit so
I found him
like King safety I'm sorry it just wow I
try to keep my king safe Daddy but it
doesn't all it doesn't always work you
love double letter positions I like
double-edged positions but I like to be
the one attacking I like to have the
initiative and uh it just feels like you
know white is at risk-free at the moment
and maybe you can throw Freddy forwards
as well just put in front of the Rook I
mean you mentioned opening the position
maybe a move like that is a good lever
uh to try to open things up oh FedEx has
to find a way to create chances in this
one right now love on aronian looks like
he's in a driver's seat meanwhile Wesley
saw also ahead in the match it looks
like he's got a good position out of the
opening playing with the white pieces a
lot of space there in the center but not
about trying to create something on the
queen side yeah I this is this is one of
those plans usually when you get these
Queens Gambit structures right these
Carlsbad structures you have two plans
for white one is the minority attack
which means white would be attacking on
the queen side with the two versus three
the other is this E4 break for white and
it looks like Wesley got it with
interest here because the pawn has
landed itself on E5 Here Comes F4 and F5
so I I agree Tanya daughter Beck is is
attacking on the queen side as he should
be but the more I look at it I'm like I
feel like this is one of those games
where notorbeck invited the craziest of
chances because he knows he has to win
but it may end up leading in a uh in a
defeat
yeah big big risks and wow okay Wesley
not following traditional chess wisdom
and playing on the side this time where
he's a bit weaker but he's just trying
to Halt the advance of Black's pawns
he's saying okay commit one of them and
things will block up he's hoping that
after B4 he just removes his Knight I'm
not sure which direction he plans to go
to let's say this one next he might even
kick away this black knight from its
nice perch and uh then it will be his
turn to start advancing the pawns and
these pawns once they start rolling will
be extremely dangerous and uh tough to
stop
looks like B4 is on the board
and uh yeah the white tonight is going
back
I'm slightly surprised that he didn't
just race towards it I agree um he
played A4 which was the that was the
move to respond to B5 but I was
wondering why he didn't just go all in
so it's one of the psychological things
that can happen when you're in the other
person's shoes meaning not not the one
playing for the must win but playing not
to lose right and and sometimes that can
backfire a little bit if you're a little
too defensive minded so
Wesley's always had these match
strategies right he's up a point he's
happy to just keep things solid and make
a draw even if he has the advantage and
look at that not a back set you want to
block me on the queen side not happening
and goes for the central break it had to
be done because you have to try and
create chances C5 I like it Simon what
do you think yeah I mean this is
starting to I think go Black's way now I
mean uh in chess you've got to take your
opportunities and uh this idea of going
for the attack it just looks so strong
uh and um and now Black's taken over the
middle of the board the the white pawns
there they could be quite loose uh if
you take the black porn Black's pieces
fly in and otherwise Black's gonna
capture you and the pawns just become
weak so actually uh I think uh I think
naughty Beck is is suddenly doing quite
well here uh he's got a nice night in
Wesley's position and uh yeah it's it's
a messy position just what he wanted
before the game started I agree
tactics hello we all hurry up a little
bit in our chairs now it takes B2
there's a C4 Pawn coming David Jacob
tell us what's going on David I need
some help here because black has given
away a piece I'm not sure which way
white intends to recapture for example
if you take with the Knight boom fork
and guess you've given up a piece you'll
regain it with maybe in Interest next
turn
neither of these pieces can save
themselves maybe you drop back with a
bishop and suddenly black is the one
with the open file Black's Rook can come
Black's Knight might start jumping into
the position certain counter play really
nice tactic there I'm not sure whether
objectively it's uh strong but
psychologically tough for Wesley to deal
with maybe it's a very brave decision by
not a bag just giving up a piece to get
his pawns rolling down the board it's
playing with fire is that a decision
that you would take on the board David
given the Mad situation
if I'd spotted this move which is a big
if no I think it's a great decision for
for nodu back he needed to try something
why not something like this and just to
show again for example Rook takes this
time C4 and either way black is going to
emerge with a past protected Pawn on B4
what's the C Pawn's name
um a couple of names I like Charlie yeah
Charlie Charlie's good name so uh named
off my cat so uh there you go C4 can be
explosive at times though it can be yeah
oh that was good it is very very nice
sorry I feel like I've been left out of
the cringy the cringy pun game stuck
between you two I just had to jump in I
have to get one in and uh but it's just
a mess now isn't it and uh loving it
it's completely chaos yep an F4 just
adding to that mess adding uh to the
explosive nature of this position now I
love it this this is awesome like this
is an e-bal bar game where you get to
say take that computer you don't know
what's going on this is not like some
position where they've calculated a draw
this is like well even at even at the
depth that is way stronger in our in our
super computer jet engine compared to
your human brain I can't figure this one
out right now this is an absolute
slugfest uh Instinct twice then if we're
struggling to work it out who would we
take I'll say black just I'm not sure
why it feels like I'm about to get
Steamroller in the center but just like
Freddie's coming to F5 I mean what do
you do what are you doing I mean I'd
like white yeah I like white yeah the
extra piece get the pawn rolling yeah I
mean I just I'd like attacking okay but
here we go five and David laughs at all
of us he goes yeah well a knight jumps
into C5 though white has some squares
Black's light squared Bishop will fight
the very uh strong Knight on C5 it's not
gonna be easy I just like the black B4
Pawn somehow yeah it feels long term if
you survive long enough then that might
play a key role but yeah early days
Bishop by five yeah blocks the pawns
move
yeah this is a very very strong move
isn't it and you're right that B Pawn if
you get to an ending probably all
endings are going to be just winning for
black uh because you have this protected
pass Pawn I had a past Pawn which is uh
got support from his brother and um
white never got this F5 move in so uh as
usual David is probably corrected
computer just says 0.0 probably it looks
like it's in the balance 50 50 here but
yeah real matter of taste because this
is anything but level butter draw
it's funny because big positional
advantages for both sides right that
Knight on C5 is so dominant it's on an
outpost Square black can never attack it
with a pawn
protected pass Pawn on B4 one of the
most long-term positional advantages you
could have right if white slips up every
end game is winning for black when you
have an advantage like that so this is a
fun one because you get those this it'll
stay equal as long as players are
playing accurate someone makes a mistake
and it's going to give you an eval bar
heart attack here because both sides
have very different advantages than the
other and slightly interesting to me
that he kept a pair of knights on the
board yes this Black Knight might slide
into C4 but it doesn't feel like it's
doing too much there and White's nights
now are just immovable and it looks like
one-way traffic he's starting to get
ready for this poor storm maybe I was
wrong Simon well that last move I mean
if you can get this move F5 in so if you
can move the pawn in front of the queen
one more Square generally that kind of
structure it's just game over I mean
those pawns are just too strong they can
always start an attack they can always
create a very dangerous passport and uh
with the last move white is obviously
threatening to to do that and can he not
just now Steamroller push those pawns
forwards get some space get the attack
going
um and it looks it looks really horrible
for black I'm surprised your valuation
bar is not more in White's favor
actually at the moment I think it's
about to happen not about just moved his
Rook on the sea line and Wesley saw
going into a bit of tank but G4 it's
coming you've got to get those pawns
moving maybe black is going to give the
bishop in the middle and give a pawn up
just to open up the position maybe this
is his idea this might be the clever way
to try and uh create some counter
chances here oh it's interesting because
Rook C3 and Knight A4 are coming yeah
this is probably what so this is
probably what he calculated but clearly
the computer didn't like something if we
back up I guess the main thing is white
actually doesn't have to take E4 that's
the problem yeah maybe you just move and
continue with your idea assignment on
the C5 is just more of a unicorn than a
knight it's dominant and magical
unicorns are they also don't exist this
one does okay
cynical Tanya cynical stuff
for all the kids watching unicorns are
real but coming to this position uh the
g-pawn has it happened G4 Bishop E4 on
the board the Queen does move Danny good
call there F5 coming next
we're doing well with predictions in
terms of moves I mean evaluation we
still have no idea but we're doing well
here and I mean normally black has to
play F5 in these positions to to stop
them from happening so that that would
kind of be my first thought but I don't
know yeah it's a mess isn't it complete
mess but exactly the kind of thing you
want when you need to win the game with
the black pieces you don't want to yeah
a boring static position you want
something like this especially against
Wesley you need a mess that's the only
thing that's the only uh that's the one
practical thing regardless of what the
eval Bar says okay and here comes F5
that's a nice call Simon because as as
ugly as that move is in some respects
and the E5 Pawn now is is is beautiful
and protected in past
you've at least created a situation
where under time pressure whites King is
going to be open you're going to have
your shots
as long as you don't miss them
yeah and The Bishop's quite tasty in the
middle of the board at the moment as
well so
it looks like a position exactly what
not a back one so one that you play for
all three results let's check back in
take this moment to check back in with
Lev on our own in against Federal Sav
has fantasy I've managed to create
anything
uh a mess another mess what is happening
here we've seen so many strong pawns
throughout the day especially from Level
neuronian white has two of those in the
center Black's King is out on a Limon G6
it's taking me a while to get my
bearings here again level material or
wait whites are pulling up temporarily
but
this is a wild game from where we left
it too because this was a one that I
thought might be a little bit of a
positional affair right maybe maybe
White's trying to poke at the light
squares and black tries to hit the D3
Pawn but they went for some absolutely
crazy crazy chess where we wouldn't have
the Queens off the board and the King on
G6 here so uh black and grab a piece if
I'm not mistaken black can take this
bishop on C1 I'm trying to calculate
here uh I think it's a key moment if he
wants to win and he needs to win FedEx
then taking this piece makes a lot of
sense now you undermine the defender of
this Knight if the Rook recaptures then
what happens here what is going on black
is up a piece there's there's two
passwords in the middle of the board I'm
freaking out I don't know what's going
on here valuation Bar says level yeah
you know what normally happens in these
situations where it's completely mental
it's just a Perpetual so yeah the rook's
probably just gonna check the king it's
probably a draw and uh you know that
that taking away all the fun Simons
they call me the Grinch the problem is
you're right especially from live on
aronian's point of view if this type of
thing occurs then then he'll for sure
take the Perpetual because that would be
a match Victory so yeah and instead
maybe in light of that feder safe has
taken a risk not grabbing the material
he still has this very strong Knight on
D3 uh he's put his work on d8 instead so
aiming to take this Pawn on D5
and how to keep up the pressure there's
two threats Rook takes pawn and maybe
now Knight takes Bishop but you've
gained a move
anyway because the Knight on G5 is
hanging so white has to deal with that
but there's
so many moves here there is a little
tactic here isn't that I mean you you
can try and uh uh take the Knight and go
into the night I want to go Knight into
the central the board Knight to E6 but
this way I I probably stop the black
Rook from taking one of my strong pawns
I love my Pawns in the middle because
this tactic that Dave is showing here
um
if I can keep those pawns but playing
like this when you only need a draw yeah
is so risky because you're giving
material up and uh it's the kind of
thing Lev would do though you know
levels oh he's such a brave player you
know he he's very calm he's got that
experience but I just don't want to lose
one of my pawns because if I do anything
else I think I'm going to lose one of my
lovely Central pawns maybe the Knight
can come in as well but
um then Black's gonna pick one of those
guys up so yeah it looks looks
interesting LeBron loves himself in
exchange sack I mean and objectively I
think it has to be one of your top
candidate moves so I
I really like that idea yeah if you
start with the night move then Rook
takes Pawn is possible there's no night
check because the Black Knight covers
this square and after Rook takes the
black Rook will land on a protected
Square so uh yeah even a tactic like
this black emerges with an extra Pawn or
well a dominant position so yeah you can
reverse engineer that whole variation
and I'm looking at Simon Just Rook takes
Knight why not looks like you also take
the nine and then play D6 oh I mean you
don't have to play 96 like can you ah
yeah maybe if she likes it maybe bishop
takes Paul now as I have to consider I
mean it's uh
you know you got two pieces for The Rook
right and this is yeah yeah if you can
stop that porn you're right and you can
just block it right so it's uh yeah but
maybe what Lev's thinking of he I reckon
he's seeing both these lines but that
that other one you showed where the
Knight goes in here that might have been
leading to some technical draw right
where you don't give up the material
this one is more tempting I I think but
it's more messy so maybe he's just
trying to work out the safest one I'll
be amazed if he doesn't go for this so
it's Lev yeah I think other players
would maybe avoid this but uh Lev Lev is
very brave player well and I also think
from a forcing perspective there's your
your D5 Pawn is hanging and the Knight
is hanging after Knight takes C1 so
objectively it's it's also process of
elimination yeah process of elimination
you might have to go for something that
uh that's a little bit nutty I mean we
could look at this Knight E6 was that
line do you think just heading to a
drawdown that you showed or if you can
pick the D3 Pawn up at the end yeah it
feels like it's a bit like had a very
strong Pawn there and yeah I think
unless Levon can Bank kind of 100 that
he's going to get a draw then he's going
to play a principled move it's his style
as we've been talking about three
minutes though left not easy and there
we go he does play it okay now that he
played it I wanted to suggest Bishop to
C5 check because once my process of
elimination we maybe figured out this D6
idea is perhaps even better than Knight
E6 so maybe black should throw in this
check first yeah and then take on D5 if
rookie three
um okay will he give a check here for to
save he's paused which means it's on his
radar a lot of players would
automatically recapture a rook they'd
see it they'd take it but black can give
a check and uh the question is how much
that changes it's a really worrying sign
there did you see it live on stretching
levonne was stretching flexing you're
refilling the beverage over there Lavon
takes a stretch yeah that means Lev is
feeling very I mean is that his thing he
stretches stretching his uh he's a he's
a stretcher lavon's a stretcher can we
just call him what he is he's a
stretcher the monster stretcher guy and
you play that kind of a move you
sacrifice that Rook that exchange for
those Central pawns you want to flex a
bit this is your moment and he took his
time he calculated it he feels that's
his best chance and fathership he's
reaching out he's about to make a move
will he capture The Rook or will he play
the Intermezzo he goes for it a check on
the board making sure the bishop remains
ahead of the pawn chain that's in the
center is there a possibility for white
to actually enter check and block this
check and he doesn't right as you called
for it I don't I don't know if it was
best or not because I I think okay I
wondered if the move was Rook takes D5
first no clearly it wasn't but maybe not
okay it's all happening so fast but at
the very least from federal saves
perspective we have a three result style
position right The Rook in a pass Pawn
versus the two Miners And if both
players get under time trouble anybody's
game
anybody's game and let's just point out
one big difference from the line that
David was looking at earlier that now
the Deep on isn't blocked black does
have the option to actually go D2 and
push that pawn but is it a weakness
David or a strength that's the key
question this Pawn is one square away
from Glory from promotion white will
block and black needs something now you
cannot allow this Pawn to fall otherwise
black can simply resign uh let alone try
to get that draw
and uh I don't see it immediately maybe
you can take this Pawn hit the bishop
and hope that there will be some pins at
the end but uh I don't know it feels
like white can simply Retreat white has
got everything protected and upper
material bishop and Knight will be to
Rook long term with the draw in hand
that looks fine so okay he doesn't push
the pawn instead Rook to see eight and
yeah still anyone's game but Levon
should be safe enough
we will check back on this as this end
game does heat up meanwhile not it back
up to Saturn is he about to make a
comeback in this match absolutely a wild
position that we have but Wesley so down
to two minutes on the clock trying to
create something on the king side
meanwhile not a bag with all the pawns
on the queen side what on Earth is going
on here yeah uh a a blunder just
happened right before we got here sorry
for the for the uh stutter there the the
speechless I it was a totally closed
Queens Gambit type of position and
Wesley bunders upon and allows the
entire Queen side to fall with it when
he lets Knight takes A4 happen or what's
funny is I was following it in real time
right as we were switching Wesley goes
for Knight takes a for Queen A4 and then
played F6 instantly as if he prepared
this David so either he blundered and
then bluffed or he went in willingly for
this line to get the Practical chances
against Black's King I know it feels
like a very strange Bluff to make unless
you've really believed it Danny and
wandering in this position what was the
idea after Knight takes E4 because
suddenly you're hitting the black queen
this Rook is protected so you don't have
to wear anything up there and you've
grabbed a piece in the meantime maybe
what he missed is that after Queen to B5
this Rook is hanging yeah so uh it does
feel like an oversight here that he just
simply missed this and uh the White
Knight would have dropped off next and
this is the ruins let's catch up with
the uh game position this is the ruins
of his position that's uh remaining now
and all black needs to do is avoid
getting checkmated and long term these
pawns should win the game wow do you
know what because of my vision I didn't
even see those pawns he just highlighted
and I was thinking oh Black's doing
quite well even without those pawns
because the white king side is actually
quite exposed I thought wow you know
actually uh in this position the bishop
is so strong uh the Rooks could easily
come in and uh that that's another
problem that that white has here right
the uh the king the king is a problem is
the white king not the black king in
more Danger
and both players touching the two minute
Mark another back under two minutes
right now we've been talking about how
Wesley is the hardest player to make a
comeback against but not about he seems
to have created his chances given that
one opportunity how close is he to
trying to get this and I see the valvar
creep up just as I see it
still feels like he's close to me this
is the most human move the most natural
move just getting out of the way of the
pawns now black is really threatening
Pawn to A4 kicking away the White Knight
and uh steamrolling steamrollering
through but yeah still some work to be
done and Wesley is a tricky customer
I've got to say this game is very
unwesily like normally it's just full
control I was just gonna say that that
obviously we've been applauding Wesley
for being such an accurate chess player
but you called out before the day
started that it was maybe a clash of
styles and I I kind of want to give
Notre back credit for creating chances
putting pressure because Wesley has made
some uncharacteristic moves in the last
game that he won kind of luckily he made
it he made an uncharacteristically
aggressive move and here again he he
made this blender so I'm
I you know it hasn't been Wesley so
formed today it's not over yet and even
if Notre Beck wins this we're headed to
overtime chess
um but uh but yeah I agree with you
David he's looking quite nervous naughty
back and his time is now under a minute
and I said his King was going to be
safer but actually now white has some
quite serious threats uh looming you
know just capture they only protector of
the black king move the other rook in uh
so it's it's maybe a very key moment in
this position no matter what the
evaluation Bar says when your king is
starting to like flutter you know feel
the pressure you've got to be very very
careful and 30 seconds now wow it's
ticking down and this this looks like a
good move wow what a move by the way he
willingly walks into losing the A5 Pawn
but he calculates that the B Pawn is uh
is gonna become a baby girl on B1 look
at that yeah nice full board awareness
really nice move to give up the a pawn
but see the bishop on e4 combined with
the Rook behind the pawn push him baby
that's a very yeah yeah agreed
yeah you're gonna make a new Queen nice
nice find especially in time pressure
beautiful calculation and getting rid of
the Queens would totally destroy White's
chances of getting an attack so uh
Wesley how does he keep the attack going
can he maybe it's impossible yeah he has
to find a way to keep the Queens on the
board what happens if you just sidesteps
on H4 yeah
again this queen is on such a kind of
devastating diagonal if it just gets one
check White's gonna be the one mated but
I don't know Rook takes Rook for example
forcing the White Queen back don't take
it with the king the black
that's a good one to show game over this
will end in Checkmate uh so Queen takes
still some work to be done the White
Knight will jump in yeah
that is a very strange decision because
well wait he took he took on B8 oh my
gosh the Queens are now off and you just
got to deal with this horrible past pawn
and uh I know what he's doing he's gonna
he's planning to sacrifice the night not
not necessarily a good idea but
surely it's not going to be enough it's
like just blocks this uh White past one
there we go and while he's going for the
black king wait is there he wants to go
to F6 yeah I think this is whoa Rook V6
rugby six beautiful oh you got you see
him then like you've seen that little
eye look he played Rook B6 and he did
this he looked at the camera because he
clearly has Wesley there did you see
that that was sexy we got to back that
thing up that was amazing he played Rook
B6 and then and then poked his eye over
there he didn't lean back he's
definitely not expecting this move Water
Resource this is in the position just
hanging a whole Rook if white captures
it black just pushes the pawn and then
you're too late with your own Knight and
Rook yeah and I did just check that was
the only winning move in the position
and he'd spotted it from afar I think he
saw it when he played Queen B8 maybe not
exactly but you see how quickly he
rattled out those moves he had really
taken his time on that and that's the
kind of brilliant find that completes
comebacks and uh
he's winning now this means that we will
have an Armageddon and if white jumps in
with the Knight again black queens with
a check yeah and uh Wesley giving a few
Spike checks here this won't help save
the game Black's King can easily run
away from those tracks Black's gonna
make a new Queen beautiful just giving
away a whole Rook for the gain of two
Tempe and that's enough to win the game
he's back by the way levona did drop oh
yeah once he saw resigned and not about
gets into the Armageddon and Danny you
were pointing at Lavon drew the game
he's through to the winners bracket he
stays there Federal save goes down to
the elimination bracket what around this
was Rook B6 that felt like the move of
the day to me David take us through some
of the big highlights in this big match
that we just witnessed yeah you called
it the move of the day Tanya and yeah we
have to see that in slow motion once
again it was beautiful from Adobe it was
necessary from Abdul sotorov in this
position it looks like the black porns
are queening but Wesley had prepared a
trick Knight to D7 and this is a really
nasty threat B2 would buy fire seriously
here due to a mate in one the black king
trapped but he had spotted that he can
get out of this by giving up his rook
and only on this Square on B6 because
after The Rook is captured the White
Knight blocks the white Rooks Retreat
and it can no longer keep an eye on the
B Pawn beautiful stuff a queen is coming
on the board guaranteed after B2 and
Wesley had to resign
What a fine that was which means we are
in for quite a ride as another back up
to such Rob and Wesley so will go down
to the wire there will be an Armageddon
to decide that match meanwhile Lavon
arunin drew the final fourth game and uh
takes the match against fantasy and
Magnus Carlson and Fabiano caruana
winning in style in just
three games what a day of chassis has
been and it does continue and joining us
right now is Love on our onion and he's
joining us from Spain lamb welcome and
congratulations
thank you very much what a fantastic
match that was tell us how are you
feeling not just about winning but the
quality of play
actually I thought my play was of a high
quality I was kind of happy with it
except the last game where I was a bit
nervous uh yeah it's tough to play When
the drill is uh you know guaranteed to
win the match but other than
that against I think I played quite well
I'm happy about them that I never
thought that I would hear you say that
you were nervous before uh the last
match it's not something that we're used
to is it because given the math
situation and the opening approach that
fantasy have had it felt aggressive
uh no not necessarily it's just that you
know sometimes
um you know I'm I'm not playing well
when I when I need to make a draw this
is not uh really what I'm good at
it's funny you say that live because I
was I was uh wondering if that's what
you were referring to and I was going to
ask
we talked a lot going into this round
about the players in must win situations
who were Notre back and federal save but
how hard is it sometimes to be the
player who only needs a draw and
psychologically wants to avoid changing
their game even though the dynamic is in
their favor so what do you do to keep
yourself in the right mindset in those
moments
it's much harder and uh and I'm ashamed
to say that I'm not really the person to
be an expert on how to make a draw
because I fail quite a few times
um so that there are better better
um guys of this so this is not really my
skill especially with white and when it
comes to playing with black and making a
draw this I'm generally pretty good at
it but with white I start getting
nervous
and a level and I'm just looking at the
room you're sitting in and I've been
admiring your your chessboards there and
your books as well is this there uh do
you have a favorite chess book of all
time putting you on the spot there
man I wish this was my room so this is
my friend's room it was a
cheers
uh journalist you probably know him
David yada so I'm playing from his place
because it's very quiet now here
so he's in a bit of a remote place but
talking about the favorite chess book
yes probably the
seven chest deadly sins by Jonathan
Rosen that's definitely my favorite
though I couldn't let you go I'm sure
we'll see you again this week without
asking how many times or have you let
ponchick play his own bot this week and
how many times have you played the punch
Meister
I think I played against punching at
least 50 times
when the last time you played against
him
yesterday because I keep on showing to
my friends and you know witty uh lines
that are prepared for punching I'm I'm
very happy and grateful to you Danny and
the chess.com team the ponchmeister
deserves it he's a bot that's what we're
referring to by the way for those who
don't get it you can play you can play
ponchick at the bot page sorry Tanya go
ahead
well I was also thinking about your
incredible performance at the global
chess league and right after that in the
closing ceremony what's left doing
playing against the pawn check bot
hello you know and I miss my boy
thank you so much love and
congratulations once again on your
performance today and we look forward to
having you back and watching all that
you bring to the board tomorrow
I'm excited
managed to strike back with the black
pieces against Wesley so one of the
hardest players to beat on the circuit
and we will be going down to the
Armageddon on the other side of the
switch break stay right here
[Music]
foreign
Ed by founder and creator of aim chess
Anton Gora Anton thanks for joining us
today
hi guys hi Daniel thank you very much
for having me here well first first
question I have for you before we get
into aim chess and and maybe all all the
great things that that those tools can
do let me ask did you ever think that
aim chest your your creation would be
the the title name of a Champions chess
Tour event
I mean that's that's a shocker if you
would tell me this in the beginning of
my journey I would say wow this is this
is super cool I never imagined this
before well let's talk about the
beginning of your journey and let me
just get to the question why did you
create aim chest what was it about
looking at the tools or maybe your own
chess path that that inspired you to to
create such a thing
so you know I was always in love with
numbers and with the statistics and I
was wondering if I can apply this uh
let's say passion to the another person
I have which is chess and yeah when I
started I just tried to understand all
right what is the difference between two
1500 players right and then I started
digging into the details and yeah and
here we go well tell me more about that
then because I think for some people
they may think well what what exactly
does aim chess do and is aim chess for
me is aim chess for all levels of chess
player from beginner to master or who
would you say it's it's target audience
is to help them improve their chess
yeah I think MTS is really great for
2000 minus players so for all those
beginners and the club level players who
want to improve their game but who is
not let's say title yet for instance and
uh yeah what Dame chess is doing is
downloading all your games you play it
on chess.com or other platforms and
analyzing it and then crafting the
personalized lesson for you right from
your own games
and the position we are taking it's
those positions where you can play
better where you can improve your end
games or middle games tactics and even
openings
anyone's that's fascinating so is the
suggestion that you get from all of your
games something you can then do right on
AIM chest does it recommend other other
tools or other sites as far as hey you
should just work on an area of the game
or is it very specific in terms of what
it can suggest and tell people to do
exactly I mean like we can be as
specific as to say like you have
problems in your Kings game bit opening
or any other one and even show you how
many mistakes you made in this position
or in that position but the true power
lies under a number of positions so
we're giving you mistakes which are
frequently continue doing so which are
repeating again and again and then make
sense to improve that there make sure
you hit your target I guess that's why
the aim chess the aim chest I guess
target practice make sure you really
know what you're aiming for so uh Anton
it's fascinating and obviously it's
awesome something that everyone watching
this should consider checking out
um how how easy and where should they go
to sign up how easy is it and where
should they go to sign up
so the easiest way is just to go to
chess.com and open learn menu and you
can find their aim chest string so just
go there put your chess.com username and
find out where you can improve right
away well um I'll definitely be giving
it a try I hope that everyone watching
this will do so too like Anton said you
can find learn chess in the chess.com
learn menu or you can just go to
aimcast.com Anton thank you so much for
being here and we're going to get back
to the rapid games uh right now thank
you thank you guys
want to improve your game click the link
in the chess.com navigation bar to try
aim chest today and increase your rating
31 faster than standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chess your digital chess coach
[Music]
it's the fastest way to improve your
chess with the fun and targeted training
unlock your potential with aim chess and
you get your first month free with the
code CCT at
go.just.com
so check that out and meanwhile it's
time for some fast and furious chess
because we are heading towards the
Armageddon the clocks are ticking and we
do have the bids by the players not a
back up to satro with 8 Minute 28 second
Rusty so wins the bid with 8 minutes 12
seconds starts with the black pieces
that was a close one not quite the
Magnus outbetting Hikaru by one second
but pretty close right I mean that was
that's a pretty accurate bid I guess as
far as anticipating where your opponent
might land and that you did want to play
Black if you're Wesley so
yeah very very close and um it's going
to be very exciting I mean I don't know
how they get so close when they're
picking these numbers
um so yeah that dates from the future
will be really useful we've got to say
Wesley's really backing himself to have
such little time such a huge time
difference here we've seen it in the
past around eight and a half minutes
tends to be the gold number so uh yeah
he's playing with fire here
I see someone's the bed we're just with
16 seconds what a bit that was and it is
a farmer that's so destructive that it's
called Armageddon let's take a look at
the format the players bid for that time
and we saw the player with the lower bit
wins plays with the black pieces the
opponent starts with the best time 15
minutes there's no bonus time no
increment and flagging is
allowed it is allowed you can ruthlessly
flag your opponent and that's part of
what you get to do when one player is
playing withdraw odds is you you get to
play to the death so and I think the
lack of increment is huge sometimes I
think we hear eight minutes and we know
these guys are bullet and Blitz
Specialists that sounds like a lot of
time without increment that's a very big
deal and I agree with your call out
David that eight and a half minutes
tends to be the threshold but when we
see players go below eight and a half is
when things get spicy but Notre back
also bid lower that's what I'm saying I
think both of these guys really wanted
black they like their chances to get a
draw
yeah it's interesting because they've
had two really kind of complex decisive
games so Wesley to back himself to go
for the draw here means he's got
something up his sleeve and we see a
repeat of one of the clashes from
earlier this time Bishop G4 uh last time
we saw Wesley choose something slightly
different but same opening from Abdul
satorophy's yeah showing he's not afraid
he just wants to keep life as many
pieces on the board as uh possible and
he'll maybe flag Wesley later yeah or at
least try to outplay him I said flagging
is allowed it's not only allowed but
it's highly encouraged highly encouraged
in the Armageddon and we've seen of
these bidding armageddon's often the
players are going for this eight to nine
minute Mark is that is that The Sweet
Spot
I would say yes just just because we see
them all bidding within that range right
and again I don't know how many of these
players are discussing it with their
seconds with their coaches with their
friends and family and with their dogs I
don't know I mean where they're getting
where we're cat wherever they're getting
advice from
we tend to see players keep it above
eight and a half minutes most the time
but again in this in this matchup these
guys did draw both their games before
the final two decisive games right so
I'm just kind of unpacking the
psychology there I think Wesley really
wanted the black pieces so he was
willing to risk a few more seconds on
the clock
bold strategy Simon we'll see if it pays
off right
yeah yeah I mean it looks pretty solid
for black so far I mean uh the the
structure we've had in most of the games
actually and uh more pieces get in
exchange you've got to think this favors
uh the side that's trying to get the
draw uh I mean look they're just
hoovering them off aren't they get the
Hoover most of them are gone already
there's only a pair of nights left and
uh they could be gone and then we get a
very pure uh colesberg structure which
David's already mentioned on on numerous
occasions and uh
um I suppose the one thing white must
rely on here is that night in the center
supported by a pawn which will be coming
up the F Pawn I I can't see what else
white can try to do really yeah it feels
like at some point as well he'll have to
generate an attack against the black
king uh it might look counter-intuitive
on the face of it because White's poor
majority is on the queen side but uh it
means it means basically you've locked
down that side of the board so you can
switch your full attention especially
your pieces uh towards the other flank
and yeah it's still a lot of life left
despite the fact we've seen all the
Bishops leave the skin remove reminds me
a lot of the Armageddon battle we saw
between nihal sarin and Anish giri at
last year's chess.com Global
championship and that it was a super
tame and we were sort of like what's
going on here isn't this helpful for
black to trade off the pieces and just
get to a simple position but we found
that Lee how was going for this on
purpose and and the position became
super simple where he just drained the
clock and ultimately they got down to a
scramble where objectively it should
have been a draw but uh but nihal
managed to Swindle it so anyway
interesting interesting strategy
to win on Demand with those extra
minutes on the clock and right now
Wesley's used quite a bit of the time
he's down to about six and a half
minutes uh what do you make of that do
you think Abdul satro of having to win
on demand has managed to keep it under
control on the clock at least on the
clock it's uh been great work and on the
board that's the bigger question maybe
because now Wesley's offered a trade of
Queens he backed up last move Abdul
sator of saying okay at least I want
nights on the board but now if you keep
the Queens on it will come at the cost
of a pawn White's porn on A2 will be
juicy up for grabs so big decision right
now on the clock seven minutes is a huge
difference especially if you can kind of
play those simplified positions that
Danny mentioned right to The Bitter End
but big decision now to take or not to
take yeah massive decision I mean uh if
you take the Queens off
um you might be getting nearer to that
draw because uh okay the queen is the
most dangerous piece as we all know uh
the only other option I can see if you
just slide the queen over and use your H
Pawn and just try and generate this
attack against Black's King and I think
in the match situation this is a much
cleverer choice and maybe even the black
queen can get in some trouble
um and this this I think quite a lot of
danger here I like it you know that move
is because now you can you now you push
Harry it's always Harry isn't it he's
such a hero
he is he needs he needs a medal a medal
that guy I mean look at him he's just
going to push forwards do some damage to
the black king the white Knight's coming
in it's uh yeah it's it's well I mean
look at the evaluation bar as well the
evaluation bar is really like I was
sitting here trying to wonder what it
was is it is it a queen trap or is it
just H5 and go ahead I guess it's just
push him baby go for the attack yeah and
then you have to decide where you put
the Knight right do you put the knight
in the middle trying to trap Black's
queen or do you go directly for the King
by putting it on this square and this
Square threatening Checkmate it looks
scary right the black queen is wet out
of play it's going to take a couple of
moves to get back in and um Wesley seems
to be disappearing into the camera as
well you know he's getting nearer nearer
to camera I mean this is scary stuff
right scary if I was facing you here
Simon I would be terrified and all white
needs to do somehow is get this queen
into the Blackberry position do you
wriggle it around to this Square maybe
you come across either way the black
king is in huge trouble sometimes you
can lift your Rook up the board and
swing it across to H3 it looks like
you've got three very strong potential
attacking pieces black doesn't have too
many Defenders so despite the fact
saying the computer is saying it's
completely winning for white you still
need the execution
and uh what do we think here G6 Wesley's
playing with fire but and I agree with
the points Tanya I forget if it was
Tanya or Simon May but someone made the
point about it was much better to keep
the Queens on the board just from a
practical point of view at the time we
didn't know that Wesley was going to
take A2 and allow this but I totally
agree and I think just letting your
opponent think you have to use the
advantage you have on the clock and it's
really paying off here just keeping more
pieces on the board and we see a trade
on G6 and the Knight captures is that a
decision that surprised you it did
surprise me I've got to say with the
pawn maybe there was a tactical I was
gonna say there must have been something
wrong with htx G6 it's the White Queen
just coming across and it would have
slid in with a nasty Checkmate some
tactics here meaning that black cannot
defend but now Black's structure is
fractured and yeah maybe it's just the
Brute Force approach push forward blow
open lines towards the black king while
the queen is so far divorced from uh the
king side I would I would ask if anyone
is surprised by by what's happening in
this game but the more I think about it
I think my my answer to the question
would be that I always give the momentum
the favor to the person who had to win
to force Armageddon right they're the
one playing with the psychological Edge
and some of the momentum is is going to
carry over it has to
um it takes a lot to get yourself
totally fresh when you feel like you
just blew it right in the previous game
and so this is this is a bit more of a
of a runaway train or a landslide than I
expected but Notre Beck has all the
momentum Wesley is uh is clearly not
himself today I notice how Wesley's
Queen still stuck the other end of the
board and the King facing fire here all
of white spaces targeting black skin The
Rook the queen and the Knight picks up
the F7 Pawn this has been Domination by
notabeck managed to avoid the losers
bracket the entire chess kid Cup on his
way to winning he barely might be
avoiding the losers bracket today sorry
I didn't mean to cut you off David but
go ahead he uh he looks like he might be
moving on and keeping in the Winner's
bracket completely agree I mean uh just
disaster this one from Wesley the
Queen's still so far away there is a
threat on the board actually of Black's
Queen taking on the G2 square and uh
there'll be a black knight Fork but
unfortunately it's white turn and I
think you're delivering Checkmate in a
variety of ways you can even slow play
it here just nudge the White Queen up to
F6
threatened Knight to H6 Checkmate queen
of night combo here is going to do the
work
you can take Black's Pawn on D5 I guess
set up a discovered attack he goes for
that latter option and how is this black
king gonna Escape it simply isn't it's
just such a greedy Pawn wasn't it to
take I mean it's easy in hindsight but
the black queen just got so sidetracked
and uh yeah yeah 82 earlier on when that
black queen went were pulling up and
that's very unlike Wesley to have no
sense of danger I think one of Wesley's
really strong points is he's got his
great sense of danger and with now three
pieces attacking free it's like the
magic number It's gotta be a check mate
right I mean that King has got to go oh
there it is
did he just miss that oh my God he
missed everything and that's it takes
the Armageddon wins the match against
Wesley so what a performance this was by
NADA back but Wesley really crumbling
under the pressure of Armageddon that
felt like not even a game I'm I'm
I'm I'm definitely speechless just just
because and it's not to disparage Wesley
in any way but I mean that's not the
Wesley so we're used to seeing that was
um he he beat himself to lose that match
found a way to lose that last game and
then completely collapsed in Armageddon
and so obviously you uh you know that
he'll have a knight to kind of right the
ship and and figure figure it out but uh
shout out to Notre Beck for keeping his
head in the game and completing the
comeback what a performance by the chess
kid Cup winner back up the statue of he
continues his runs stays in the Winner's
bracket in the aim chess rapid as well
what a match this was David it ended way
too quickly what happened there yeah a
premature finish there but uh it just
shows that Wesley so wasn't on form
today it was a master classroom after
but a disaster class from Wesley so and
I Just Want To Praise this one move uh
we'll show the Checkmate in a moment
again but dodging the queen trade here
at the cost of a porn was what clinched
it for Abdul satorov trading Queens
would have got the game closer to a draw
Queen to C2 even sacrificing this one
was a move of genius and Mark of Genius
here H5 kicking away the Knight and the
attack simply proved to be too strong if
we fast forward now to the closing
stages we saw this position Black's
Queen still just far too away from the
rest of her Army and uh the closing
stages Knight to H6 met by King h8 a
blunder but King G7 wouldn't have been
great either this would have led to a
nasty night for King h8 though and
Quincy 8. good night where's Lisa
what a game that was by Abdul sattro not
a bag a mousetrap inviting Wesley's
Queen to one side of the board and
checkmating the King on the other side
of the board and with that naughty back
up to sattro makes a big comeback in his
match taking the win in the Armageddon
and the other winners and Magnus Carlsen
levonaronian and Fabiano caruana stay in
the winners bracket
why do they have action this was and the
one man who did what felt impossible not
to back up to satra winning his match
against congratulations
thank you
what an Armageddon that was it got over
too soon it felt super smooth to us did
it feel as smooth to you while you were
playing were you surprised how quickly
that went
yeah I got very comfortable position out
of opening and yeah everything went
smoothly I guess
yeah apart from that yeah I mean I was
of course
very happy to to win uh on demand as a
game four
of course I I wasn't of course I was
I didn't believe that I can I can beat
him if he plays like normal just because
you know his I'm a solid player in the
world right now I think
so yeah I was quite happy to to
uh yeah
I was quite happy to beat him on the mat
yeah it was awesome not about we were
talking about how Wesley is one of the
strongest players and the hardest
players to beat on the circuit and you
managed to do exactly that I want to
talk about the bid a little bit you lost
out on the bed Wesley got the black
pieces but he lost by 16 seconds were
you really hoping for the black pieces
there
um no actually I just uh
I just bid
um a28 because you know I think it's
too little with you know playing with uh
seven minutes or less because you know
it gets very tough at the end so
yeah I wasn't uh actually
uh upset I would to you know to lose a
bit but
um yeah so I just played with white and
everything went smoothly
Anna do you have a particular strategy
in mind when you have to play these must
win games
um I mean do you just like go a bit wild
or what what were you thinking before
that must win our beginning game
well I just wanted to create some you
know playable position with black
because you know if you if you play some
you know gambits I think it's not good
strategy
to you know to play for a win from like
move move one but uh you know if you get
some strategical position where
uh where you can create some
messy position like in the middle
where your opponent have spent some time
this kind of situation is I think very
uh very good to you know to to have a
chance to bid so yeah I think I got very
I got very lucky that I managed to you
know push my pawns and I got this very
strong
before which decided the game so yeah it
was very
um it was very pleasant
and another back you're doing great so
far this season on the Champions chess
tour you won the chess KitKat last time
out how do you make uh yeah what do you
think of your chances of winning this
tournament as well
well it's too early to to judge but yeah
I'm just ready to fight and
I will give my best and we'll see you
another bag it was an awesome fight
today I want to get your thoughts on
this bidding Armageddon because it's a
new thing in the Chess World
armageddon's are always so exciting and
now it's with this twist where the
players bid for time do you enjoy that
what are your thoughts on that
yeah I think it's very interesting for
fans to you know to watch how uh how the
players are approaching so yeah I think
it's very
um you know very new and very exciting
thing and yeah I'm just
very excited to to see that
that's really cool to hear it's a great
match today congratulations once again
and we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
not about
there doing the unthinkable he not only
strikes back in his match levels of
score but then takes the Armageddon in
crushing Style with the white pieces and
that means at the end of the day this is
our bracket and the action that's coming
up we will have not a backup to such off
taking on Lavon aronia and take a look
at that we've got the 2018 World
Championship rematch that's Fabiano
caruana takes on Magnus Carlsen it's
gonna be a fun day of chat Simon yeah
that pairing Carolina versus Carlson
that is just mouth-watering and uh I'm
very much looking forward to seeing what
openings they come up with and how they
play yeah don't forget that uh Fabi just
beat Magnus in soccer when they were in
the rapid portion before Magnus woke up
and went on a Terran Blitz right so
Fabiano should have some confidence I
think heading into that matchup
certainly knows that everyone and their
cousin is going to be talking about the
2018 rapid affair because you have to
but uh I we could talk about every
single one of these matchups they're all
going to be great but I there's no world
where we don't Circle that one for
tomorrow yeah and a bit of a bonus we
have the appetizer of the Elimination
Brackets uh plenty of big games there
with a lot more at stake tomorrow
how
it's going to be a big day of Chess at
the aim chess rapid as the players
continue their fight to win that golden
ticket to the Champions chess star
playoff but of course the fight is also
on in our other two divisions and we got
some shocking update when matlakov had
just three minutes chose three minutes
for his Armageddon Getty what happened
today uh get us up to date with all the
action from the other two divisions well
Tanya in the second division we sat at
the beginning that the tabatabai was a
big favorite he lost the first game and
it was sort of wake up call for him
because then he won all the three games
and won the match as well the biggest
upset is Dennis lazovic beating Parham
who is so experienced Grand Master at
the beginning of the match perform was
absolute favorite but 16 years old
Grandmaster pet him and goes to the
Winner's brackets and in the division
three we had a clash of big names
fresina versus chronic the that much I
thought would continue longer but it
ended just in two games as chronic just
blundered exchange and fresnet took it
and won the game so that was it in the
third division uh and I'm looking
forward to see more blunders and
sacrifices tomorrow
that sounds super fun Kitty thanks for
that I've been out to ask you what did
you think about this this crazy
Armageddon that we had the big comeback
that we had by norderbeck against Wesley
that was a fun one as well
sorry
it was indeed it was a great day of
Chess and as Katie pointed out some big
upsets there in division two and three
uh what a day of Chess it was Simon what
was the big highlight for you
I think the comeback right I mean uh who
would expect naughty back to first of
all beat Wesley with the black pieces in
the last game and then destroy him in
the Armageddon game I mean that was that
was pretty shocking actually so yeah
great play from the youngster David not
about so many reasons to be pleased
today yeah no they're back on Fire
Starting uh with a bang but for me it
was the form of Magnus Carlson Fabiano I
was especially enjoying magnus's
openings and uh the pose that he gave
for us uh enduring one of his games I
would say Lavon too I mean he may be
flying a little under the radar but I
mean he might have been in the best form
of all right he uh he said himself that
the other two players maybe were as
complimentary of themselves Magnus and
Bobby but Lavon was like no I think I
played really well today until that game
where I struggle a little bit to play
for a draw when I'm leading a match but
it's uh the stage is set right we've got
a lot of people who seem to be on form
and uh here we go
here we go it's exactly what we want and
we've got a big matchup coming up
tomorrow with a Magnus Carlsen taking on
Fabiano caruana on the very
informian playing against not a bag it's
a day you don't want to miss and we will
see you here we'll be back with all the
actions same time same place
[Music]
foreign
strikes again
I said it before he played it he gives
up the queen and that's it finally yeah
does resign
he doesn't know how to do it
oh my God Bobby played the pre-move
victory Saga goes down and Fabiano
caruana takes the match
the Armageddon wins the match
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign